welcome to my show
hey
hey yeah you're skinny boy all right hey
i have a question and i have a question
yes how about this
no right away let's move on it's
important to ask a question because i'm
looking at you i don't like this either
okay i haven't seen you in person right
so
we you don't get some we know that right
now it's not a big deal but
if you do a special you know
casper the narrow ghost hahaha that'd be
hilarious nah dude right but that
wouldn't be that funny but you got to
get some color dude i just i'm i'm a
different you know what it is dude what
i'm built different we have a backyard
though yeah yeah yeah yeah but i'm built
different yeah but what does that mean
dude like
you know rappers say that [ __ ] yeah i'm
different i'm
you know how like like [ __ ] workout
guys would be like built different yeah
yeah they i am well not them i am yeah
you should wear a shirt that says beast
mode that'd be sick that would be very
cool you know your belt might be very
yeah you're built like if i had hey hey
man turn your chair yeah yeah just give
me the shoulder yeah yeah if there was
like a four camera
it was all and we couldn't and there was
a tiny little sliver like you're the guy
who's
and kind of gets through it you know
what i mean like
i don't know i don't think that's
anybody said no it's like you gotta
[ __ ] you got to seal the doors even a
little crack and he [ __ ] [ __ ]
like an x-men
yeah the awkward guy you don't do
anything you just get in there and
you're like and you're all drawn so i
don't help at all he doesn't have to
keep the [ __ ] wall we don't help at
all yeah you drink all the water somehow
to get like and then we all die and save
life oh yeah you die anyway yeah like
that's a bad movie i know i know but
that's that's what you would start hey
dude you're behind me right yeah it's
bothering me yeah shoulder with a cold
shoulder yeah
behind your shoulder rolling rolling
right so let me take this off
uh obviously if you guys don't know who
these two are i don't know what the hell
you've been watching over there is chris
delia one of the funniest man on the
goddamn planet yep has a
the biggest podcast in the world
congratulations
and that's me saying congrats you said
it was called you're welcome right you
says you're not it's just not called
you're welcome
yeah that would be a cool yeah you're
welcome
like moana you're welcome i know that
song well i sing it to calvin yes so do
i
just to calvin yeah i sing to him on the
phone that's you i facetime him dude no
you're outside yeah streaming outside
across the street your son you know wow
he's been sending me emails yeah now i
want you guys to know that brent and i
have a 2 000 bet
on the uh peter yan of course danny and
fight okay and if you don't pay me
you're gonna see me beat brian with my
bare hands after the show that'd be fun
that'd be good context all right good
yeah yeah i can't wait yep
who are those guys that you just
mentioned oh okay so they're the fight
that's going on that's right
they're the co-main event can you name
one ufc fighter yes go ahead the rock
good
good yeah what weight he fights at what
do you know what weight he fights the
rock is 550 pounds there you go that's
right this is all correct 550 pounds
those are actual
wwe that's good
all right let me get this reading kids
all right uh this holiday season we are
giving thanks to our friends at
manscaped the global leaders in below
the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 or as i like to
call it the perfect package for your
package will beat any holiday spread
this year
gift yourself manscape because you're
all hairy down there man all right
once you get the package inside you'll
find a little lawnmower 4.0 trimmer it
you can do it in the in the dark you can
shave your pubes is that true yeah man
if you want to get weird do in the dark
doing the shower all right they get the
weed whacker definitely something you
could use b for your ears and nose hair
because that's not fun crop preserver
ball deodorant okay crop reviver toner
we got boxer briefs in there and a
little travel bag to put all your stuff
in all right we got you covered man
yup little ball bag the gift of manscape
is the gift that keeps on giving and you
want to be shaved down like a seal this
holiday season get 20 off in free
shipping by going to manscape.com
cfc that swipes off free shipping by
going to manscape.com cfc be thankful
this holiday season for the best gift of
all from manscape your balls will thank
you
good read thanks guys i'd like to end
when you did that did you
yeah it was cool man you think you're
stronger than a rock
uh
i uh maybe at some things i doubt hey
yeah but he's constantly just working
out yeah like never stop that's all he
does yeah i don't know well how big he's
as bit he's as tall as you right like
what are you six
four he's probably six uh yeah he's
about six four i'm gonna be with him the
rock is all natural though brennan is
doing nothing but steroids so there's a
difference right
yeah if i was on his protein powder that
would be pretty close i don't know dude
his genetics are he's obsessed big
strong guy so a better question be if
not you you right
you're past that but for you chris if
you got on that stuff you think you
could get like uh like john cena i gotta
get on that [ __ ] i thought about getting
on that [ __ ] and just being [ __ ] for
real different just a different guy yeah
and just [ __ ] yolked as [ __ ] like
not but nice you know what i mean like
i'm a nice guy yeah do you know what i
mean
like hey how are you doing but like but
like when you shake my hand you're like
oh that's a tree trunk okay yeah
i know okay well i think what would
happen because because my frame yeah is
from the from the chest i hate saying
that you gotta frame but no but it's
ridiculous right and dude no but
my legs are thin yeah yeah and that's
and they but that's it but not here
though but right here above my knee
they go crying
they go crying
because you know the drop it looks like
a teardrop they don't cry and my hips
are like this
no no yeah dude and so it's crazy so
people call me chicken legs because it
looks like i have full chickens in my
legs no that's not good yeah yeah
yeah so i don't think that's what it is
because what happens is
you you are genetically not
an athlete right so you don't have you
don't have the ability there's no power
from the waist down no no
you got tits yeah no you don't have an
ass right hits bro what i have an ass do
you it's crazy not really hard you go
crazy
yep now if you if you
saw stuff in my car if you saw something
yeah i think i'm gonna one day though if
you went to zoo culture and started dead
lifting and and squatting yeah what
would happen you you're the expert would
i blow up if i did but chris got big
just doing the that whatever [ __ ]
videos he's posted in his house like
jumping on like boxing oh i jump crazy
around i jump around crazy dude yeah you
got a guy that jumps yeah pretty
baseball like you're back like yeah for
real like you got pretty jacked you
didn't actually get thick and strong i
don't say actually
all right because it happened right yeah
don't be like actually yeah you know you
actually got like like you didn't
believe in me
you believe in me i know but this [ __ ] i
look like captain america when his
shield is at rest right it's on his back
i don't know that's me dude oh like a
turtle yeah turtle yeah your turtle yeah
yeah what what have you ever been in the
sun though why don't you get out dude
you know what it's like you're the one
all scared of covet sun beats that [ __ ]
i'm not i'm here bro you guys have
coveted for sure dude we got vaccinated
and we had covered what's up daddy we
like the ex-money cove bulletproof yeah
bulletproof sneeze in my [ __ ] mouth
chris
no that's yeah even though i see what
happened pre-co what happens
nothing yeah well it would be gross no i
will lick your face in your mouth uh
there will be a lot of weird memes about
it that would happen yeah sure so yeah
um no um nah i i didn't get covered yet
and uh i'm chilling dude are you bubble
boy people talk people dude i i'm out
and people are [ __ ] talking to me and
people lean close i feel like the people
i feel like the anti-vaxxers lean closer
now just to prove a point for sure yeah
hey real quick okay be honest with us
all right do you wear a mask in the car
no
i thought you were that that's a stupid
[ __ ] thing
because he calls me from his car and he
has a mask on he just calls me like this
and
uh he never has clown masks because he
wants me to see the smirk on his face
he'll call me like he's won something he
just calls me up and and i'll be like he
facetimes and he's just going like this
yeah
and i'm like i'm already annoyed that's
nice yeah but you're a good friend it's
all good baby yeah see that bothers me
it's all good and then he moves doesn't
matthew mcconaughey has that thing just
keep living dude me and matthew
mcconaughey are like right there
together oh he's running for god just
keep living i like him very much i'm
going to be here a little bit when he's
sitting there like when he's making that
inspirational speech you fire your hair
no no listen to me man anyone who makes
inspirational speeches yeah just stop
doing that that's right well then stop
doing it
because they give one hell of an
inspirational speech before you run that
tough mudder i don't think i'll ever run
tough mudder man why not
you wouldn't run it with me it'll be
dirty have you ever i don't think you
run [ __ ] hey hey [ __ ] dude a little
mud yeah nah i just like
what do you wear nothing what do you
wear just your shirt and tee
hey he's grooming his son to be exactly
like him his son is one years old and he
spends all day with the sun which is
beautiful but his son there was he had a
nice coffee with a straw and you see his
son just go like this
down and goes and he starts to sip the
coffee at one and chris goes yeah
be like me
dude dude i let my kid drink coffee he
drinks my hot coffee man black coffee
the first time i went to give him coffee
i was like because he's like he didn't
want to grab he just wanted to grab
anything you know he grabbed the straw
and kristen was like uh well i don't
know i mean give him a taste because you
know it's bitter i like it black i'm
real man and i don't put [ __ ] in it
except for ice cream
[Music]
so i was like she was like it's true
it's true
sweet tart tart and ass and they're like
this hey i love that come on i'm about
to my brian dude i love when fans go
yeah brian shaw yelled out be gay out
yeah he doesn't like that constantly
no you guys give me nicknames and then i
just never lose them rings yeah i hope
they don't say that and in brea this
thursday oh no you [ __ ] yourself up
i'm saying i hope no
you're there thursday friday well
thursday friday when i'm doing it now
why aren't you doing saturday because i
got the fight companion
november 6th oh yeah that's all man but
i but november 11th to the 14th when i'm
on off the hook come on
that's in naples when you're you want to
m.c for me no dude in
naples come out it's nice to have 10 in
front of you
15. if you want all three an extra five
that's all you got now you haven't done
stamina yeah but dude i've got 20. no
i'm not no he's been getting up
you shake
all right so what was i saying
dude that's nice oh calvin yeah so we
drank coffee and my and kristen was like
you you have it you know give it to him
he won't like it and he goes
and he goes ma ma
dude he's yeah he's me
okay
no he's me i get it now now that i have
a son yeah
he's me dude i mean
another me
that's so egotistical no
i made another me i will live forever
i could die now my lineage
we'll move on chris that's not the
reason i have a kid you have to there's
no i love him i know but it's also part
christie he's
me
dude he's part christian but when you
look at him in the face yeah he's
nothing but me
dude he has the eyebrows
yeah he's me dude his eyebrows are on
like mine on top of his head like a
[ __ ] cartoon okay we are one
chris you can't do your kids come
through you not from you you've got to
be a little bit less
like egotistical about this
does he have a shoe collection already
like yeah he does he doesn't have
anything he is my spawn no he doesn't
have your hair no but he will dude i was
blonde when i was a kid i was a little
blonde boy dude all right and then one
day i go like this
nah and it goes
and it's dark because if you're a blonde
haired man yeah you're a [ __ ]
you are dude you are a lot of blondes
dudes at my shows
and that's
no
cap
that's zero cat tell brian what that
means so that means it's not a lie
i'm telling you the truth true
and i don't want any blonde
men at my show and here's the other
thing too if you're a blonde man and
this is a rule you don't wear a leather
jacket because no matter what you're not
that cool
no leather nope
nope
jan
and and the other san diego
yeah and cory's saying we had a lot of
blonde fighters in this in this thing
coming up
i think hooker has blind hooker does too
dan hooker doesn't like sandy he's a
handsome dude by the way i'd like to
just before we get into this i got can i
give you my picks for this for this
sure all right so i got peter yan of
course and i'm gonna win two thousand
dollars yeah dude you better [ __ ] pay
me i'm gonna pay you all right i'll pay
up i don't have to just make your friend
pay them no i don't have to i got i got
i'm i'm going glover
yeah i just i'm rooting for him
man you don't know how to do a fist bump
no i don't know how to do a fist bump
ah [ __ ]
these pics let me take a hand
dude just make a fist hold the fist
though you're not a pun
um chris real quick you watch no sports
no i saw no football no fighter mcgregor
uh
khabib yep
[ __ ] got
connor
mcgregor that's a long time ago mack
hold and that was crazy
but i will say it's a good fight i got
in the left's like the next big thing my
favorite guy is
another another jacket with a chin sharp
beard yeah uh zendaya style ender
he literally said that he literally
style underground
style ender is so good
what's his name
izzy would you call him izzy
i like that guy i saw i was uploading
one night uh watching youtube videos
exactly guys he's mad that's
unbelievable yeah i love that when he
says you would like him to be a swag
yeah yeah i see him no i know i'm joking
around i know what his name is when he's
fighting he's a puma athlete he's a
beast when he's fighting calvin and
there's that
clip where he says there's no problem
here i'm prepared to die
that's what i do uh in now in the middle
of my set when i'm on stage i'm prepared
people are just laughing their [ __ ]
ass off
and i and i very quietly say
there's no problem i'm prepared to die
only about half of them hear me because
the laughter is deafening okay
why do you say there's no problem here
the way you talk about your son talk
about your son normally
okay okay what's his middle name oh [ __ ]
um
you don't even know
matthew
is it yup because that's my brother's
name that's bill love it calvin matthew
dalia i did the same thing yeah
matthew
no character my brother's name you
didn't name him after your brother you
have a brother yeah you've never met jay
kidding bro get with it man there is no
problem i am prepared to die
now i got
it yeah yeah
so what's up yeah so here we have a live
event this is what you wanted me to do
right yes here we have a live event
we've got three chicks sitting on the
sideline and we've got a guy here now
who are these guys can you explain it no
over here in the red shorts we've got oz
dimir and then uh on the black shorts
here backing up we've got enclave oh
nice
gadir's got uh now he there is no yeah
there is no uh there is no doubt that
his fight is
well he's losing the fight against his
hair loss right yeah he's thinning up
top
um they're dancing around and it's uh
honestly how hard uh would it be if if
every dude if if
like who's announcing these fights uh
john hannick maybe bisping
paul felder all three of them
so that so just so chris you see the guy
on the right in the black shorts yeah
he's from dagestan okay and dagestan is
slowly
slowly taking over everything oh really
in fighting yes now you made up a place
dagestand so uh that's a great company
that's right that's where khabib is from
it's it's it's it's it's somewhere it's
it's
by john
you go through a wardrobe right and then
you get to a lion and you can actually
ask it questions and he tells you where
dagestan is yeah that could be right
right right right yeah but dagestan is
near azerbaijan kyrie
made it up
um and they uh are uh very very strong
they're the toughest hufflepuff oh dude
so hit so the the guy who fights on the
i think he might be after this
right chin magameth him and khabib grew
up together
sorry marcus as kids they went growing
up as kids children think of calvin
doing this yeah they would carry rocks
and go up the mountain yeah
just for the fighting is like their
national sport so you're playing rabas
with your brother it is they're taking
goats they put them on their backs
they're the hardest crazy man and then
suck in this goat what yeah dude
no no the
they are the hardest people on them so
i'm trying to tell you don't let calvin
fight yeah because that's his
competition
these kids are eating grass yeah it's
crazy
it's actually crazy um but you have you
have dan hooker over maka jeff
just because i liked it i'm super biased
yeah the chance of him winning is not
good but i got it mike will be the next
55 pounds 100 i don't know how you're
getting absolutely how you deal with it
how do you deal with it i mean you're a
coach he hasn't put it together yet
fully oh yeah like josh thompson trains
him he's known him forever he's like in
the training room he's the best i've
ever seen he's like so what you guys are
seeing right now in the ufc he just like
when it's a main event he just hasn't
lived up to his potential yet right once
he puts it all together because he's a
better striker than could be jesus he's
you know his wrestling uh grappling not
as good but still a 10. could be just an
11. good guy but his striking is
superior to khabib's
where where did he learn striking aka or
just aka started in dagestan uh starred
in dagestan yeah his his coach was also
khabib where is this guy uh on kalev
train out of
uh
do you like chris edward narnia
narnia with the lion that's crazy he
misspelled venom on the back of his
shorts
it says venom yeah in a cool way
because they're like you're into merch
yeah i have
okay don't be cocky and don't do that
are you gonna flex on brian right now no
it's just
it's cute when you say that okay man
i'm into merch talk to me in a normal
boy or is it the
people that are into
my merch talk to me in a normal voice
and don't be condescending okay okay
okay all right yeah i i just i don't
take that vein in your
your torch is still going with it merch
is still going well
you guys
oh god damn it chris it's it's going
well yeah
yeah guys
yeah yeah yeah it's it's going away all
right dude okay fine dude that's how
people are right
that's how those business guys are how
are things it's uh it's it's going good
it's it's not it's
this bothers me ask me how how things
are going how are things going having a
lot of fun
a lot of you get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah
i'm just really blessed
i'm blessed
unemployed but you're having a lot of
fun it's going that bad huh that was
always the thing in acting whenever
you'd ask in la when things are not
going well it would always start with
they'd always answer in a really weird
way like how's it going yeah no things
are i got a couple projects
man here we go
so this is not the
this is the fight before the main one no
there'll be five fights yeah but they're
all like killer fighters
i honestly
i mean he's a beast
he lost his last fight and then they
give him this monster yeah i'm not doing
many favors i watched a few uh i watched
maybe the last two um ufc's yeah with
your girl or what yeah um
oh that guy who i mean that guy got beat
the [ __ ]
but kept going awful uh that was brian
uh
yes ortega and i i was i said they
should stop that fight when he said one
finger two he said two after that
you know it really pissed me off that
guy's too tough for his own good he's
two i know i'm right he's next video
i couldn't believe i don't know a
[ __ ] dick about it but i'm like oh
that's just got to be unhealthy does
your girl like watching it no she
sometimes she goes in the other room oh
wow because it's like because she's like
i can't i can't we let calvin watch it
um i actually uh set him up with vr
goggles so yeah so you learn to figure
out how he can learn and he's it's very
intense for him
he cries but it's like hey dude that's
what he did he's got to get through it
yeah
he's got to get through it right and he
does no after i take it dude when i take
the vr goes off five hours later he five
hours he gets with the fight
so he he's going down yeah he cries for
him you know they do say the children
who watch it their cortisol levels go up
and all that oh dude if i put these
fights on right now because boston grew
up watching it yeah he's two he'll go
like this nice well your kids are your
kids are built for war yeah your kids
are different they're they're built for
sport and for combat they are tiger lost
his tooth last night woke up crying was
like dad get my tooth out the the money
maker yeah so i went all right you look
like a hockey player so at two in the
morning i pulled the tooth out he's like
just he's crying i'm like dude this is
great news the tooth fairy comes now you
get money he's like really
daddy don't have any cash so the tooth
fairy gave him a 50 gift certificate to
starbucks
and he goes so he wakes up this morning
goes dad what is i thought i was getting
cash i go just because cash dude
tooth fairy tooth fairy's been working
non-stop i didn't have time to get cash
you little [ __ ] so here's 50 in star
buttons you like the the cake pops just
as good there you go cake pops are good
that's he was [ __ ] hilarious you know
what you should have done that's a bit
what you should have done
when he said dad
i got the starbucks gift card what the
hell you should have flipped your
[ __ ]
lids
and you've been like
you aren't great you're joking right
and then he goes no look and you say let
me see that and then and then you go
like this
[Laughter]
the next tooth you lose
i'm going to wait up with a shotgun
and when i see
that tooth fairy
i'm going to blow her [ __ ] brains out
he's five soldiers
he's five bro
he's five
i don't know if that's good dude see
this is why honestly i think you guys
are bad dad no we're not hey and you
need to understand how to teach yourself
you let your kid fight on lessons no i
do keep my son away from his mother
that's what the spartans did and he does
sleep with him sleeps on a marble slab
and he eats from a bowl of gruel yes
face down on a marble slide yes and he
will train he will train um today's puke
day he runs hills
but he's ten he's ten so he's already
so that guy is too bloody
he's getting beat up pretty much wild
and dagger standings they have like a
distinct look don't they yeah just not
much of a forehead yeah beard they don't
see not a lot of male pattern ball in
the state they seem to have very good
hair lines scary and just tough
toughness well their nose has been
broken their nose was already broken and
yeah look at his nose my friend's son
uh wrestled in azerbaijan for the next
five
and the way they train the way they
wrestle and the way they train is you'd
get shut down you'd get shut down in the
united states yeah yeah so how about
the guy who fights net next hamza comes
at daddy before he was in the ufc
remember connor was talking [ __ ] to
khabib and some other guys about being
dagestanian
he had he was like 1-0 yeah he wasn't in
the ufc he flew to [ __ ] ireland to
find connor and beat him up
uh dagestan yeah he got stopped by
uh police officials at the airport they
could they contained him for i think he
said seven hours didn't feed him or
anything he was like you gotta get back
on the plane and then he flew him back
because he lives in sweden they flew him
back she flew him back flew them
there you go take down take down chris
inside trip take it so there are the
other brain busters crazy it's right
back up though by the way look at his
leg look at look at doug uh
on a club's back of his leg he's been
taking some leg
oh yeah this guy's got some ham hocks on
him yeah big strong guys it's crazy when
their [ __ ] hamstrings pop out like
that like biceps you know what i mean
yeah it's crazy when their hamstrings
pop out like biceps
uh
yeah they were
these guys are wow they're really going
aren't they
did you did you ever hear did you ever
hear you know how john hank has to do it
and like when it's like the prelims he
has to give like backstory to some of
the guys yeah before i say this there's
nobody that i love more than jonathan
he's so good but he's trying to fill
there and he's like yeah uh you know i
forget the guys names like robertson
domestic violence case going on
yeah and it's all quiet in here
so anyways he's 3-0 in the ufc you can
hear the whole broadcast like okay and
annika is so good man i don't know how
they do that
dude vin scully used to do it alone with
the at the dodgers like with the dodgers
yeah yeah baseball though you know yeah
well that's there's more down time yeah
exactly yeah but you have so many guys
like batter you know next month oh right
you're just talking about one guy here
we go yeah but still at least there's
actually
four last series against the reds
yeah to be that knowledgeable is [ __ ]
crazy though like
right it's just like yeah well that's
crazy especially this card especially
this card
[ __ ] so many guys from russia and
dagestan and europe so the names are
look at the names
yeah i know what those are but honestly
how does but attic never fought how does
he get to be
he just came up with so good or what
he's just how do you smash i understand
he started on espn he's just like those
guys are special good the guys
yeah all those guys on espn those those
they because they started a lot of times
i wouldn't say writers but a lot of them
like a lot of them who started out as
sports writers they just know sports you
know smith started sports yeah that's
what i know
i think it was uh i think it was
chicago i think he started in chicago or
philly a lot of those guys skipped
something he started in dallas he was
the cowboys good writer
good writers yeah and then they have
personalities and they're [ __ ] oh
look at his eyebrow
oh damn jesus christ hey being in boxing
they'd stop that fight right no no it's
not bleeding into that oh [ __ ] dude
check hook oh
[ __ ] it just splits open could there be
a tougher way to make a living it's so
hard dude
and then chris you'd quit there because
what would you do if calvin when he's
like
yeah or i would just be like
you know dude ship them to austin and
ship them to rogans see what wrote you
doing [ __ ]
i don't know yeah it's a bit you don't
but honestly like you don't these guys
these guys haven't been older yet you
know what i mean what do you mean
like like these guys just get knocked
the [ __ ] around like there's nobody the
ufc is relatively young like when these
guys are 70 yeah
it could be at times you saw what
happened you know what i mean you saw
what happened to muhammad ali it's just
like yeah yeah you know i don't know if
you guys know muhammad ali was like one
of the greatest
boxers box of different sport yeah it is
a different sport and you're right but
he took a lot of yeah it is it is a bit
in its infancy as far as like major
sports yeah but you're seeing more and
more like you'll see some guy you know
i'm not saying names we see some like
hall of famers where you're like
yeah that's how this ends yeah i know
it's like like uh coleman was like yeah
i need a hip replacement oh well that's
not good you die if you break your hip
you're dead yeah
no that's not you're dead nope nope
you're dead no you drink you drink
mcdonald's coffee huh yeah i used to you
and i used to be close and then yeah
okay that separates us a little bit okay
why huh no no no you know what let me
get this straight why not
let me tell you this okay you pull up to
mcdonald drive-thru in a ferrari i have
and order the coffee
yeah
have you varied your diet or do you
still eat only uh dude i'm saying
white bread turkey i don't eat white
bread i actually did eat white bread but
i don't eat white bread that much yeah
what do you what do you eat i eat a lot
of you know bowls rice bowls
dude you know
yes asking a question you know i eat
have you checked have you checked to see
if you're malnourished no dude i'm just
a certain color because i'm built
different okay have you got any more
tats
no but i want oh no but i got one coming
up do you think your face is getting
your back it's going to be
see okay
i'll tell you what you're gonna see it
okay yeah but i'm not gonna tell you
what i'm gonna do and when i do it you
know get my dates tattooed to your back
dude the thing is
then the dates will pass and they won't
be for promotion anymore so that's a
stupid idea but just as a this is the
guy
no dude i'll give you you should get my
name tattooed because i've been such an
influence
dude comedically
no look at me no no look at me i'm
looking at you
i'm not getting your [ __ ] hey
did you take your workshop
he did you did you used to study me not
a day went by that you weren't in the
back like this when i was riding
just [ __ ] pulling [ __ ] out you and
dove
yeah yeah and he'd be like this
learning
i don't make that i don't hear him i
heard somebody at the wait said you know
what he was doing and he was going like
this
no i don't say papa when you're on stage
well you used to when i was your
teacher no you're not i was your
guru no
don't say guru yeah i was your
guru
no you were the mama bird bee yeah he
called me sensei for a long time i
didn't you did under your breath
sometimes
i shouldn't be tired this is nothing i
shouldn't this is unfair to do that he
would come to me like this with his
hands like that
why because you just you needed me to
fill your hands with knowledge
i don't know how
i have this drunk girl thing but i don't
know how to do it
that was a while ago yeah dude that was
a while ago you have uh coasters for
your own [ __ ] yeah yeah pretty good
you've heard of espn right bro it's not
hey hey
you've heard of worldwide of sports i
mean honestly no i haven't heard of that
really yeah i know espn but have you
heard of nbc
i'm just i've heard of nbc dude i worked
for them for a long time so yes i know
and you know it's like a network yeah i
get it dude
this is the thick book hey hey chris
it's annoying it's called dick point
network dude
i wanted to be called
i want it to be initials or something
espn nbc your face is so turned off you
want me to call it tbn yeah dickboy
network tbn we can call it tbn
hi uh brandon chop for tbn
do you own any thick boy merch
oh you know do i own any i don't know
what i need but i would like to have
some yeah but i'm not i'm not thick do
people wear it and they're not thick oh
yeah really that's a lifestyle dude take
your stick don't say it's one thing
hey thick
it's in the heart oh
i
gotta
go
[Laughter]
hey man let him just be let him let him
market his stuff dude hey yeah no hey
it's just that's what he's doing a lot
of people in the heart thicknesses
and he'll get drawn in it's hard to
resist but it is it's right here
where it's in the heart man
yeah here's what happened dude yes have
you seen dune when they did you see dune
yet no no no no i won't either yeah oh
dude how come
and i think midnight mass that series is
overrated i'll fight
one of my favorite people in the world
and to see her she's so good one of my
favorites she's amazing
i did it
i wanted to talk about dune but it's all
good
no we haven't seen it all right have you
seen speakers
oh so yeah so in dune
there's like a voice that you can do
like he says like can you pass me the
water and she's like use the voice and
then he goes like
bust me the water and and she just goes
tomorrow and gives him the water that's
what that thick boy thing is yes
yeah don't do that i'm sorry anyway dude
sorry that would have been a much better
joke had you not broken off into
everything netflix has [ __ ] streamed
into the past [ __ ] three months
you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey
it's good yeah it's good that's good
it is it's it's it is good but it's
crazy to me the the the
the madness around yeah it really is
stereo really is yeah it's good though
i'm not not no hate i just i'm shocked
it's so [ __ ] big
i i i thought it was really well done
yeah yeah yeah and if i hear brian say
one more time dude the way it shot wait
you love it i loved it i thought it was
i surprised that you're a big fan of
koreans oh they make some good [ __ ]
they're great
i like their culture i like yeah no
horror
bro
you don't want to talk to me about
korean horror films i know i know my way
right
so you're going to be all alone
have you seen jen that's a that's a
that's a well-known one sure yes
like you're back in like a conversation
it's not exactly a deep cut
yeah give them some other ones
you know what brennan
yes that's good okay
man you're being so condescending like a
real estate agent
what are your favorite korean
uh
horror films um uh
there's i i don't know
i honestly don't know what the [ __ ] i
thought you guys i don't know
korean names
no but you speak just honestly asians do
horror way
yeah it's like legit although i will say
um i saw the ring uh american version
and then i saw the ring
what you saw the ring
yeah
no but my point is the american
version's better i think everyone's like
you've got to see these did you see the
grudge though yeah it's scary yeah the
new one's way better
there's an american new one oh there it
is yeah it's good oh way more scary a
new new one yep that guy is the biggest
in the world yeah
it's the biggest one i've ever seen now
he's finding that pluto uh uh ireland to
fight conor mcgregor
the tall one yeah yeah another dagger i
mean you know
just rough oh christ that's crazy
yeah these guys are
they're fighting today yeah right right
now don't get me wrong it's a great
fight did we bet on this chin dude no we
should though i think we do we it's
coming about a bottle of whiskey of
choice
or money all right how much money all
right 500 500. hold on chin are you are
you taking care of i got legion he's so
like uh he's an underdog but i'm still
taking no i can definitely see him
winning
500 contracts nightmare comes out
tonight i know but we but here's the
thing and i heard the espn like
you know guys the gambling experts yeah
like calms out but so you got to
remember he hasn't fought in a [ __ ]
year that's true yes he did yes struggle
with kovacs yeah so we don't we have no
idea so for him to be a minus whatever
500 is insane yeah
because at the end of the day those guys
don't [ __ ] know that's neither do i
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] this comes out from
chechnya or is he from dagestan i think
he might be from chechnya let me look it
up real quick just in case i'm with
chris on this i feel like he made it up
made it up
comes up
he is
is such a nightmare
fight's not up that yet though you know
do people know the guy didn't show up
did you say why to people because
remember that josh oh sorry uh
yeah josh thompson's not here
he's sick not covet he just had like flu
cold light symptoms and he has to fly to
dublin to work the bellator card he's
like dude i don't wanna fly to la
i gotta get over the sickness so he's
gonna be on next saturday the next uh
calabasas oh he wasn't even in l.a no i
have a flies in from san jose i have but
he's on everyone that's like how come
you have
uh 747 tactics hey talk about being a
road dog tell them tell them about life
so i travel a lot for stand-up comedy
jet setter
etc and so i got a plane
on my wrist yeah on my well that's on my
wrist is anything worse than uh telling
people why you get the tattoo but i mean
yeah i mean
it's personal i know but it's like you
know it's like one of those model
airplanes that you have as a kid and you
have a tattoo do your [ __ ] it's also
spared airline plane which drives you
nuts yeah whatever i told him give me
the spirit
i want that spirit dude make sure the
plane that you put on my forearm is a
plane where the seats don't go back i
say that's yeah and he goes spirit
airlines
do not touch me
dude you got a really strong you have
strong physical boundaries i'm trying to
do yeah well i'm trying to do the
[ __ ] voice um
yeah does that you talk to your son do
you do do you think you make me drink by
myself oh i'm sorry also
hey you're sober huh
i don't drink yeah
okay guys i mean don't make me don't
pressure me and you come in here with me
dude this coffee is good for mcdonald's
mcdonald's i mean i would never eat did
you get a [ __ ] mcflurry no dude i
don't eat that [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't you
just get the coffee yeah that's it i
don't you don't like you don't like to
make riddles come on hey hey hey
honestly hey
listen hey can i say you don't like the
hashbrowns
i like the hashbrowns i'm not saying i
don't like biscuit sandwich yeah
hey chris who [ __ ] went um dude
homer's here
biscuits dude
i uh i don't uh oh oh they're gonna kiss
what dana's looking thick huh i went
down dana's looking very thick he went
down
he goes down hey
you may grill it dude
of course it's good it's engineered to
be good do you let calvin eat it
no i don't want him to eat it but
sometimes what's wrong with you well i
mean yeah every now and then he
can i say a sentence without you [ __ ]
all right sorry man sorry
god dude he he eats it sometimes i know
that kristen sometimes is like driving
around you know just [ __ ] like and
she's like i gotta get [ __ ] you gotta
get them feeding before i get it yeah
and that's fine i don't want to be a
[ __ ] nazi about it you know what i
mean you don't want the weird kid
mcdonald's again like i'm not yeah yeah
yeah but i'm not gonna get that [ __ ]
you're better than calvin you think
you're better no i don't think i'm
better than calvin but i'm not gonna eat
you do you eat mcdonald's you don't even
need [ __ ]
here yeah this guy's a yeast i did the
other day though i went to the airport
and i had a
taco bell no no i had i was the airport
i had hash browns and i had a uh uh mc
mcmuffin [ __ ] delicious i know it's
so good it's [ __ ] delicious the best
i got
[ __ ] postmates cinnabun at 10 o'clock
last night you pieces cinnamon wow
you're a little bit of a fat kid at
night when the sun goes down that's
where you get turned into
i'll tell you right now i don't like
cinnabons
yeah because you're very disciplined all
through the year i don't
it's too much
it's too much dude you know you can get
just the middles with icing now i will
fight you yeah you don't like cinnabun
it's a little bit much too much
you put it in your mouth and you go
where am i yeah it's too much i put in
my mouth like you know this is heaven
you can eat and then i and then i then i
forgot myself to throw up afterwards
wait
you don't have an overwhelming sense
that's way too sweet yes no
okay no i will say this i like the way
you're reacting but i disagree
i like that you are standing your ground
but i disagree really
if i had a box of them do you think you
could eat all of them in a sitting for
real bro like this like this yes
and they're done like the kool-aid man
dude really cookie monster it and then
how do you feel afterwards terrible fine
and i ride my bike for 40 miles wow wow
do you know that they say if you have
lots of muscle glycogen you use the
glycogen your muscles actually shut up
thanks chris
shut up dude but i just that's boring is
[ __ ] all get out dude come on let me
speak let me be glycogen well look over
at me first of all dude hey glycogen is
[ __ ] boring to talk about dude hey
let me tell you something i'll look at
you but when i turn my head
you better be in a lab coat
because you're talking about glycogen
now
if you're not in a lab coat you have to
stop talking
would you look at that
hey
hey
this is chris one time [ __ ] glycogen
hey this is chris it's me rogan it's
just a bunch of comics at the comments
we're just sitting around in the parking
lot i started talking and i said one
thing i go well historically
hey chris goes oh jesus christ here's
brian ready it is boring brian again ah
i'm brian science science history
history
go ahead
one book you bread dagger stan
dude
okay
i don't know if that's
i don't know if that's [ __ ]
very uh in 500 on this geno yeah let's
do it this is the one that's like
i like where you're going with this i
like your loyalty or well he's chinese
he's chinese this guy's relaxed he's
asian though this guy shaves his
underarms relaxed
this guy shaves his heart
this guy's very very shaky hey uh russia
would be considered
asia
uh um
it would be considered eurasia
eurasian anywhere
eurasian land but then also downtown is
pretty asian it's super asian yeah and
then also orange county orange county so
anywhere at la yep yeah but but it's but
it would be technically you could
technically say that but i would say
it's it's considered the arrangement or
you know chris
because it's connected oh this dude's a
[ __ ]
warrior
he is a [ __ ]
like a bad guy from big trouble in
little china huh dude he's no joke he's
clearly simone he's such a beast he's
migrant
but now how tall are these guys five
four no no they look small no these guys
are actually he's probably not a star
he's probably about
oh really
well i know china but that specific part
oh i don't know but they're i think
they're teammates i'm going to say he's
near by the way i looked this up i think
he's near in the gobi desert i think
he's from mongolia i think he's from
that part of this
yep because uh homeboy raped so many
people right he spread his seed uh yes
uh [ __ ] uh um genghis khan
i know that mongolia you know chris
[ __ ] lineage of scotland he raped so
many people he spread his seat mongolia
though uh they have wrestling they have
uh they're big wrestlers in mongolia
brian tell chris how they survived on
horses they were the first dude
i don't want to know i already i've
learned that and i let it [ __ ] leave
my brain i don't need to know that put
it back together you know do you know
how the do you know on long trips how
the mongols survived when they were with
the horses what did they do [ __ ] yeah
dude what'd they do tell them they eat
tell them what they [ __ ] eat dude
whatever the postmates was back then
okay no that's not
correct
it's close but it's not correct take
another guess
i don't know i just know that they
couldn't track it while it came to them
because there was no phones no they
would drink their horse's blood they
would tap a vein and they would drink
mares milk
and blood and they would from they would
mix it well you know what i do not know
this that's not good that's not good no
that they did that they shouldn't have
done that and you know how i know
they're all [ __ ] dead now okay
fair point fair point yeah well this
what what does it say does it say he's
from what part of china
originally same part as uh i'm going to
say the kobe didn't serve from the same
problem not sure but it says
xinjiang china but but brian you said
this get up but brian you said
that this guy's thick he looks lean as
[ __ ] he's leaned off but his head's thin
yeah he's he's lean but i i when he's
probably not training he probably goes
up to 190 195 yeah but still i would say
he's thick yeah look at him so different
parts of china zhang whaley and uh other
different different parts but i'm sure
they're i remember they were like
teammates or they they know each other
really well you know what's weird is how
we have all these issues with china
right and then the winter olympics is in
beijing yeah and then we all gotta go
then pretend everything's all good like
they're not taking hong kong as slaves
and [ __ ]
on the uyghurs
what'd you call me the weakness call me
a wigger yes you know i'm saying the
weakest that's offensive the weakers are
they're muslim
who are in at least
yeah at least dude ers guys
wow look at this
look at him talking now he's excited
this is gonna be so awesome this is
great minus 600 is insulting yes i know
he's not my 600 i would give him uh
minus 200.
because we have no idea he's been out
for a [ __ ] year he's been fighting
his whole life look at him this is where
he belongs let me take it easy bro he's
excited
he's excited and that's what i'd be you
know what's weird i was watching the
embeddeds and the weigh-ins there not a
ton of people came out
um like to those like you know in vegas
or wherever like atlanta for say like
it's packed but it is that that jazz
island area so it's got to be you got to
fly in from wherever it is it's weird
though right like yeah watching and i
was watching them do their open workouts
like jesus christ there's nobody there
chin can you locate on a map what town
where he's from what province i'm going
to tell you it's close to that guy's my
first ref in the ufc is that right yep
herzog is he what's his background how
do you become a ref you train
i think you just like fill out some
paperwork and then you're you're there
does that happen all brian
what's happening the touching presidency
i'm right perfection i believe that's in
the kobe desk driver here we go china
want 500 cash daddy because my kids oh
damn you took him down
because when my kid's tooth falls out i
need cash
also just go to the atms
now you're dealing dude
most places
look he was talking to him
but yeah comes out that's way better
graphics oh there's a little uh uh oh my
god oh yeah that kid that went viral
right now he might be four oh he's oh
he's older he's like 40. oh wow he's
been he's not that old
he's like 18 or not 47 years is that
true actually he's 18 or 19 yeah he
didn't get a star but he's super famous
now bro
i don't know if his teeth fell out yet
fear
um
look at him he looks mad yeah he looks
mad he's [ __ ] pissed the kid he
should be happy is he hums that's
winning is that true that he's 18 or 19.
yeah brian
okay i thought he was 40. he said it
he wasn't he's supposed to fight chin
that was like i think it's a running
joke i'm not sure if he was actually
yeah he's going to be well he would
another
lose
dude
same kind of condition
how do you get him off your b look at
this he's just he's just it's a
nightmare look at his hips and just i
know if it's gonna be this then hanzo is
gonna win for sure okay i guess well
let's see because he's not you know damn
look at those sounds look at that
handsome [ __ ] on the left
dude is that lewis dude just [ __ ]
jesus christ
from dubai do you know how rich those
saudis oh dude yeah but bro that guy
[ __ ] prunes for sure
oh so it's paul felder oh it's d.c
he's just dude look at those sounded god
i wish oh yeah oh that's bad
that guy's tough as [ __ ] right on the
left
yeah
he could take it would it be a cultural
appropriation if i wore that saudi
outfit is that frowned upon no no
people were they're bringing another one
hey chris i don't know if you know this
hey dude hey just hear me at what i'm
selling thobes that say life rips ooh
that'd be cool i'll buy one is that
offensive hey i'm a lord though you're
what a lord see chris see what he's
doing now chris he's flattered
he's just gonna okay well i don't really
understand what
i
the
[ __ ]
almost done it's almost done you can't
just stop it you can't defend himself
that's a nightmare he's so [ __ ] you
can't get him off you oh you know what
they say they say this isn't even a
ounce of how talented he is
he's no one's been able to push him no
they
oh here we go
it's over
god dude he didn't get uh dude you uh
[ __ ] lead and get a punch off oh he's
winking he's winking at him hold on
let's see
who's winking there's got a gun water in
there oh this is [ __ ] tough
it's over it's over well what
how did he not sync it yet honestly
it's over but wait let me hold on hold
on i don't know how he's like passing
out yeah that's what i'm saying god damn
how's he not passing out oh
dude [ __ ] dude let's see hold on oh
that's tight that's oh it's over your
face
give me five hundred dollars hold up hey
chris i'll buy you a [ __ ] cheap
coffee still like yourself oh he's
always up i'll buy you a cheap coffee
for mcdonald's damn i thought it was
gonna be a striking match that's good
too whatever wait a minute give me 500.
i'll give you 500 bucks tomorrow man so
he was that was fun to watch dude he was
just going to pass out the [ __ ] up no he
passed out look he's still out yeah you
want to try it yeah he no but i'm saying
he wasn't going to tap hey he wants
right no
didn't you
yeah i did yeah chris if chris gets into
something he's in here yeah i know but
he never got back are you still buying
kicks
still buying kicks nonstop
i stopped because of the pandemic it was
like i'm not you're not wearing them
anywhere bro you know i want those oh
damn it talk about the mummies yeah i'm
talking about those yeah so annoying
they sent me these earlier all right who
by the way by the way
you may as well just hand comes out the
[ __ ] belt now for 85.
well oh oh no first of all he's 70. hey
dude is there stuff to eat 77.
yeah dude i catered we got nashville
chicken hot sandwiches when you get done
yeah but you only get it if you're funny
[Laughter]
that's crazy because he was fighting at
85.
who is that 70 right yes yeah who is
running who's running the show oh
what happened
the
nightmare yeah the nigerian nightmare
shout out to krishna koi you know what
now who went to azusa pacific i know
chris nakoya the nigerian who do you
play for
uh he was uh come on daddy
west
rival of my broncos ran over steve
atwater steve atwater ran over steve
atwater played for the
giants
that's right the chiefs the giant chiefs
all right guys this holiday season
shout out to manscape the global leaders
and blow the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 chris as i like
to call it the perfect package for your
package this holiday season give the
gift that keeps on giving and keeps your
bush trimmed all right with this perfect
performance package you get a lawnmower
4.0 trimmer a weed whack for ears and
nose crop preserver ball deodorant all
right don't let your balls get all
stinky they got a crop revive or toner
yeah dude we got boxers in there a
little travel bag you put it all
together we got you covered man listen
it has a led spotlight so when you're in
the dark you want to shoot you meant by
that yeah you can do in the night
yeah no in my eyes i have not vision oh
wow but but that's cool because he eats
a lot of carrots
all right we'll get 20 off in free
shipping by going to manscape.com cfc
that's 20 off and free shipping by going
to manscape.com
cfc be thankful this holiday season for
the best gift of all from my friends at
manscaped your balls will thank you
i did that again kids back this is um
[ __ ] rock yeah don't be mad at my
reading skills no well it's not hey i've
worked on it no you hate
hey what do you mean you've worked i
worked on it dude i like your reading
skills thanks dude
hey i worked on it okay can you explain
that please sure you just read more okay
and then you say it out loud so that's
because i have to do 25 reads a week
dude okay so you've worked on reading or
s or or the way out loud oh okay i
understand yeah dude he had a little
speech thing going on okay
all right dude
i'm not bullying no it sounds like he's
blowing no i'm not dude i'm not a
bullying
speech impediment i don't think i didn't
even know you had a speech better i just
thought you always had cupcakes in your
mouth oh my man
oh i get it he always has [ __ ]
cupcakes or cinnabons in his cheeks no
man that's what i thought that's not
what you thought you'd be sorry
you're not
i'm gone okay but don't
okay apologize for that i'm sorry i
don't i'm sorry i'm truly sorry thank
you i'm sorry and i also i'm sorry that
i thought no that lamp was from the
middle ages
that's a tiffany lamp shane have you
ever heard of tiffany
shane hey you ever heard of nbc
have you ever heard of
change it you've heard of like fox news
yeah dude i've heard of fox news this is
tbn
[Laughter]
you are going gray yeah i am i am we all
got grace that's funny coming from you
well i'm just i just appreciate that my
friends are getting older and catching
up to me i i can't wait dude i
i can't wait until however many years it
takes i walk in and i'm [ __ ] like
that guy from the virgin airlines guy or
whatever the [ __ ] richard
i'm gonna grow it out i'm gonna you know
what i'm gonna do get [ __ ]
white contact lenses
dude i'm going to be you look like a
white walker yeah bro and i'm going to
do comedy like that
and people are going to be like i don't
know it's kind of distracting but in the
thick of my [ __ ] act when i stop and
i say
it doesn't matter
i'm prepared to die tonight they
understand do you understand they
understand now i had to dig deep in my
memory to remember what that saying was
but i got it
because i'm a professional it's called a
callback and i do call backs yeah and
when i do yeah they hit you like that
waving deep impact that comes and hits
the [ __ ] dad and daughter that's
what happens i feel like do you remember
that movie i i do do you know why i
stored it in my brain
just in case i needed it okay and now
was the time okay because i'm a
professional okay you know i've never
said that before you have but now i have
okay chris
and i will say
you're welcome no i'm going to clip this
part
put it on instagram okay so the world
can see you know you're actually i'm a
professional no you're acting like a
messiah you're you have a messianic
complex admit that so in doon
[Laughter]
unbelievable
you're you're being you're being
grandiose
and very very you're turbo arrogant
right now you need to dial it down
a little bit do be hum say something
with humility okay be humble say
something that makes us realize you're
actually humble okay say one thing i
will yes so
this is the thinnest my wallet has been
in a long
that is time humble no i thought it was
one of the coasters and i go oh it's not
but yeah it's usually yes it yes it is
that's a gucci wallet right yeah that's
a gucci with a snake on it and you're
saying well it just usually doesn't fold
right right
because you're not
it's too thick is that what you're no
because of his merch right the so the
yes life rips [ __ ] make friends in
the comments [ __ ] well you know you
know it's like no
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] usually [ __ ] like a pops
like a booby trap right but
yeah
you went late today yeah
yeah
yeah did you did you train this morning
or you just wake up
is this early for you oh yeah oh it's
seven oh it sucked waking up because
you're a night guy yeah well i'll tell
you why
this place it's too far
it's uh we're we're
is awesome if you take a nice drive
though if you take i i i go pch i love
it yeah i like it here i live eight
minutes from here but
now um
that's rose number jonas and she's
phenomenal that is and she has the lord
is that fight next shin is that not on
this card is that next week it should be
next week
the card next week stacks
wow
is just
so these these women can they beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you yes
yeah no
my uh my speed my cunning my fight iq
my
my
you know what happens i go like this oh
i know you i know what you watch me i i
know what you want chris what i bet you
watched logan paul's fight
oh i watched it yeah yeah
now he's exciting mike tyson can i get
your oh i actually have thoughts on all
this boxing [ __ ] that's going on and
with like the youtubers and the real
well the youtubers yeah it
honestly if you're taking it as
seriously as logan paul and [ __ ] uh
jake paul then you know they deserve a
chance to box right i mean but like it's
clearly a market for it they're making
millions right no i understand that
you're also training hard for it but i
mean that though i you know i think if
there's a market for it who gives a [ __ ]
i agree
yeah but it's yeah no one's watching
it's like what do you do but it's well
if it's but but my question is and i
don't know much about it but like
the it's really [ __ ] irresponsible
irresponsible is that the word not
irresponsible right
so
so that is general so wait what's your
thing oh yeah you're saying so you're
talking about
isn't it irresponsible for a guy to just
be like okay i want to box now and a
year later get in the ring and like
they're going to [ __ ] somebody's
going to die they train for three years
but they're not they are they are but
some of the guys aren't right yeah but
jake and logan but the rest of the
youtubers that no one's taking seriously
and they're fighting another youtuber so
it's like i know but isn't that
dangerous not really no they're those
are they they're not fighting other
professional guys so they're
like like if you and brian want to fight
that would happen well well well they
well now now though you've got logan
fighting mike tyson i'm i'm amazed at
his he's got balls he's gutsy
imagine if
imagine if calvin's logan paul right
yeah and he's whatever 23 years old he
goes dad i'm going to box i'm this big
youtuber i'm going to box and go all
right cool hey and i'm going to fight
floyd mayweather and mike tyson you'd be
like you're out of your [ __ ] floyds
much smaller much smaller that mike
tyson has the power to knock it still
knock you into the next but chuck
liddell made a good point uh when he's
on food drinking watching now available
now on uh
uh chuck liddell said uh he goes
he goes because i go would you fight
logan paul he goes i would fight him but
it'd be a fight like i'm i'm going to
fight him i'm not going to do this
glorified speech yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and he was like with mike tyson how
do you see that going down it's a
glorified sparring match because tyson's
not going to go crazy well if you look
at what tyson and roy jones like that
wasn't a real fight no no they're older
guys and they didn't really hit to the
house right right so he's like i would
like he was i'll watch it but i'd love
to see if tyson actually like brought
the real fight to him well also tyson's
about 55. he doesn't get a bit of it if
he but if he gets close and he that that
that's sort of like it does matter
though because if the rules are and i'm
saying these are the rules but the rules
are oh wow i knew no no knockouts to the
head not no you know no you know okay i
didn't know they were going to have
rules like that i don't i'm not saying
they do have rules like that but chuck
point was its glorified sparring like
they're not trying to take each other
out he's like i'm down to do it but i'm
gonna try and take him out yeah
yeah i think uh either way but jake's
but see logan and jake are different
yeah logan's going for the biggest
payday the most views the floyd
mayweathers mike tyson's chance of when
that fight's not good right so for him
just to survive as a win for him he
makes all the benefits
those guys
but jake's actually you know his fight
against tommy fury like tommy fury's a
real professional boxer i respect that
like tyrone woodley's an actual
professional fighter ben asked in the
natural power but that's so different
than boxing isn't it well
yeah that's different because he's not a
striker in any fashion
jake paul is serious about it and and i
respect i think you're not saying
no i i do respect that and logan paul
these guys they have a work ethic they
have that that midwest farm boy work
ethic they work their ass well and
they're smart business big and athletic
and strong yeah athletic
athletes i saw i saw logan the other day
he was he was at the laugh factory and
and we you know we were like hey what's
up and and he had that
like that
it was like a brand yeah you know what i
mean like when you shake a fighter's
hand
it was like uh yeah it's like a it was
really he'd keep you busy chris yeah
he'd keep you busy well if if you guys
talk i don't want to fight dude you know
what i mean
what would you say
what do you say i went on a show i was
like dude you would love him yeah yeah
did he do it no we were butts he he uh
but that was just jokes and honestly i
uh you know
it was fun yeah it was but you know a
social media beef
yeah it's not real what do you say
before you fight a man me yeah
i i uh
i just laugh a lot you do i laugh a lot
yeah i laugh i kick back i laugh so hard
if somebody wants to fight me i'm
because i know
it's not going to be good for the guy
right it's not going to be no and then i
don't mean like i may lose yeah but
we're both going to get really hurt yeah
he's going to remember you yeah so i go
i laugh i'm you know i i i i just crying
and then i get my blazer on and i fight
i fight with a blazer on you like a
gentleman yep just a blazer
okay yep good
night yeah
nice
i think if any fights you're sorry to
break that up i think if any fights can
go decision it's going to be this
i wish i when i died
i brought a big bowl of [ __ ] pasta
and just ate it while you're doing this
no no no no i don't even mean about
hungry it would be so awesomely
respectful that i was doing what i
wanted in front of you guys oh okay
i just feel like a pasta just a big uh
i'm talking about nice
more disrespectful a giant ham
just a big ham and you look like it's
going no big turkey legs
like a big thing up just crunching in
the mic yes yeah and just didn't give it
any to you a leg of mutton just a big
piece of mutton yeah
yeah yeah
god i really [ __ ] up not doing that
what's your last meal
the last one you're not a food guy so
what would be your favorite food is he a
food guy no he's not i'm not i'm giving
[ __ ] about food dude you don't all right
well what do you mean i don't know
[ __ ] living he likes food you go to
[ __ ] you go to ralph's and get a
mustard and i don't cookies
mayonnaise dude
so that does sound nice
i asked okay
i made my son and myself
buttermilk crepes
heavy on the eggs and i made a pork
tenderloin yesterday so instead of bacon
i had pork tenderloin
very very lean pork that i rubbed with
coriander
and and enough spice a proprietary spice
mix i dry rubbed it
and then i baked cnn too well no i and
then i i put some maple syrup on my pork
it was [ __ ] delicious dude
that's
yeah
no i know
right i have the most boring
conversation of all time for you okay
bye
sorry dude that was guinness book
dude
that's that's super disrespectful
i was just telling you what i had you
didn't ask me this no i know i didn't
yeah but he it started with what's your
last meal yeah yeah yeah
it was my fault yeah but yeah we're
going to be in uh the new
2022 edition of
guinness book of worlds okay
what do you guys do anything for
halloween yeah do anything with calvin
uh yeah you guys trick or treat around
the hood
yeah we go to uh
inglewood yeah oh you're going to dress
actually that's nice you're going to
wear it you've got to work because they
built the stadium yeah yeah so far
you're going to not wear a costume but
still go as a ghost
no i i am going to wear a costume hey
dude i get what you're saying all right
or you could put that hoodie up and just
be vampire
why don't you say vampire because you
you should have i can't believe you
don't have a romanian accent it's
incredible i don't even know what a
romanian accent
you talk like this
you know i'm not really i'm not a
vampire what is your nationality so i am
uh italian
[Music]
are you jewish chris
no i'm not jewish
i'm italian i am um
irish
and polish have you done ancestry.com
but how did you get so no no
no the less male and the less clicking
boxes i have to do on the internet the
better sure i don't know but if you were
like i'm from oh yeah but if you said
i'm from slovenia and
this accent is this for show business
but you actually had your real the way
you spoke really was i'm from slovenia i
had to learn how to speak like this yeah
so i wouldn't get typecast as as you
always say the [ __ ] bad guy in the
taken movies yeah yeah and that's
disrespectful and i don't like that you
say that hey look i'm getting ice oh
dude coveted city
dude
how about i kill me chris's house yeah
what last time i mean this was a long
time ago it was that high to cover i'd
give you that we didn't know what was
going on i didn't know what it was
he made me stay six feet away from him
in his backyard outside mm-hmm now let
me ask you a question yeah out of the
three of us yeah who didn't get coveted
all right true
hey you bubble baby yeah yeah
but uh brian almost died i no i now i
have crazy community brian was so sick
you didn't really not you huh oh dude
don't be so cocky about he was biking he
was like 40 miles that's right carter
got better now i will say this though i
did [ __ ] with my taste buds
real strong coffee real spicy food right
real cinnabon 19 cinnabons yes
my buddy got hit his head and he lost
his taste for life how bad would that be
yeah
i would like that because i'd be scared
i'd be skinny i'd be skinnier well yeah
like i like some people here's here's
how you know you're actually fat is even
without my taste buds i still like pizza
and and [ __ ] chipotle burritos oh wow
yeah because i want the texture no i
want the texture yeah yeah that's a fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] for real
you you uh
nighttime is when you watch tv and eat a
lot of that binge watch i've been doing
all the shows i've been doing that when
i'm really stressed i do that when i'm
really stressed yeah
daddy eats yeah yeah
i don't know but daddy also works out
yeah so it balances itself out so i
don't look like you know butterbean
right yeah so uh you eat at night i do i
thought you didn't i don't now i do oh
really yes now it's okay brian tell them
about nightshades no at 54 now i i do
bad things man i eat ice cream bars i
eat i go crazy i know really i really do
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it it's my my taco my
girl my girl was like brian what you got
to stop i'm i'm eating i ate pringles
crackers
i don't like pringles no i'm a junk food
right now wow and then i made my own
bread maybe and you look exactly the
same i know that's the that's what i
know it's like if you're you're just
cause i tried a guy like i don't give a
[ __ ] i know you look exactly the same i
stopped working out for a month and it
didn't really i didn't look that
different and i'm like it's so difficult
well we got different body types yeah
i'm sorry but it's okay you're handsome
you're good you have something about you
i work out a lot
you don't i don't you're it's just you
hey hey b you could get with
[ __ ] thor i could take steroids and i
wouldn't grow some people just don't put
on muscle no
well oh brian doesn't do that you just
well i feel like you just don't eat
enough yeah i don't know i think this is
it's just his build that's his dna
that's what it is that's my building
twig
i'm a thin boy hey i'm going to start a
merchandise i'm going to start a merge
line called finboard t-h-i-n-n-n boy
guys i want to thank you guys for
demanding that and i'll get that merch
out dude thin boy's not part of tbn dude
come on have thin boy let's have a thin
boy branch here
good
like one room one room that's thin boy
it's real thin
yeah just a tiny room
um
you know what you
should have more merch why don't you
have more merch i don't know i'm
terrible with that stuff but i mean i
should sell it when i'm in off the
comedy club in naples november 11th to
the 14th
get your tickets
chris if you're looking to get up this
thursday friday the haha in l.a run my
30 minute before i shoot my special next
or 11th through the 13th in dallas
yeah or come down to brian there in
dallas yep um but i'm in l.a thursday
and friday oh where at the haha i
[ __ ] love that place so
you're shooting it in dallas where uh
addison improv oh really but the
backdrop it won't look oh gotcha we're
building a whole set are they okay so so
are they because
what is it a half hour specialist are
you doing
and like i don't know what comedy
central does now i haven't worked with
them at a long time
you didn't it might be oh got it okay
i'm definitely gonna do that i'm gonna
do a half hour too like you said yeah in
january
so uh
and
see i like that dude thirties yeah man
it's the it's the it's the
it's the way to go i don't know it's
just like
it's so different now and it changes so
much well i told you when i went
literally met with netflix and i'm like
yeah no matter who it is chappelle
rogan burr
everybody stops at 28 minutes
so weird why would i give you guys an
hour yeah if we know especially my demo
1836 i'm like why would put an hour if
people are just gonna
watch 28 to 30 minutes yeah why would i
i'll just save the other 30 and put out
the following right so i'm you're
getting more
content yeah yeah instead of just
working on an hour for four years i just
like you're doing 30 every two years if
you look at guys who put stuff out on
like uh
the best is i don't mean interrupt you
the best thing i was telling rogan that
you know rogan's savage
dude it just 30 makes sense for me blah
blah i go like why do we do hours
because i want it
i don't know i know he goes no that's
what i want to do
that's what that's what i want to do i
like doing hours yeah
that's old school though i think half
hour makes a lot of sense
it's harder to do a half hour in some
ways because you have to be more
disciplined you got to be more you know
fat yeah you got to cut the fat
half hour sometimes it's harder doing
shorter a shorter special is harder than
a longer special in a lot of ways i
think i think it's because it makes you
more disciplined more discipline you got
to cut the fat and then you got it has
to be 30 minutes if it's going to be 30
yeah fire fury yeah well so you got to
figure out what to put in what to take i
got that
you know that don't look you don't want
to follow that i'm going to do
a a one-minute special
oh that'd be cool just fire for a minute
fire release on tick-tock fire just a
tick-tock special yeah just
nah put on youtube yeah
just a f not even one of those what do
they have those shorts now not even that
a full fight with a crazy good intro
yeah
it's 30 minutes of intro yeah and then a
one-minute special just
but but you have no idea how many jokes
did you ever see oh guys are fighting do
you ever see
maria uh bamford she did that she did
that
that that one hour special for her
parents just her parents
so funny so funny dude i have nothing to
do with kevin hart's special where he
know all right did he do it in his
pajamas or some [ __ ] yeah
they wearing masks that threw me off no
no everyone got uh i think they they all
got tested as they came in in his house
yeah and for not being like tour
material and [ __ ] monster yeah i love
kevin i love it um yeah he's great
i i don't like tattoo bro but i will i
will say i don't like any specials that
are not just
regular specials meaning i just don't oh
you mean like out of the house i just
think they figured out how to do it well
and and it's just and it's just pretty
straightforward and anytime you really
[ __ ] with it i just feel like it takes
away from it i know people try to get
like fancy with it like yeah i mean i
don't blame them for wanting to do
something different because i i think
that that's cool and i respect it was it
gerard carmichael i could forget who was
who's the guy who's in uh get out the
black dude he's great
oh ken no how dare you uh he wrote it oh
oh do you know what i'm talking about no
no he he didn't get out he's a [ __ ] he's
like the comedy uh
scroll down literally oh yeah
out of a gym of like compton gym yeah
yeah yeah but that was the sound was
different but it was cool that it was
different yeah and but that wasn't that
different i mean it was a little
different but like
you know what man i called you once this
is a long time ago and i said i have an
idea for you
and you
uh said i want to know what your ideas i
don't think i ever told you what it was
i think you did but my idea for you was
to do this is before netflix yeah before
netflix was a thing i said 20 years ago
it was a long it was yeah it was like
maybe 89 80 or 70. i said to him i said
i think you particularly should do a
special in front of no one yeah you i
told you that yes yes i remember that i
i i thought that the only person that
would be able to do that would be you
100 yeah i just think he didn't realize
the crowd's there yeah yeah yeah yeah
but but i also that's something
different too like i think joey diaz
should do like a uh
the same way johnny cash did i think
she's trying to black and white in a
prison yeah
some that's a good thing you know weird
things he was thinking about that
actually i think joey was thinking about
doing that it's tough to get cleared
from the prisons i think well didn't uh
there's some guys who've done it before
like paul rodriguez did it i think a
long time ago yeah yeah couple guys joey
diaz oh no no black and white no it
would be cool yeah yeah yeah with any
background
sometimes i think getting too creative
with the special itself it takes away
from it yeah i just want to see the
jokes you know that's what i learned
from from that showtime just like the
state like even when i walked out like
they sent me a rendering of it on paper
and i was like well that looks cool i
just didn't know yeah oh my god this is
distracting what is what the background
said like job
yeah brian's so funny he comes he gets
the he gets there he goes
what are you gonna do with these letters
after the special
i'm putting my backyard
what do you do with it mix them up spell
something cool yeah i don't know man
yeah they were so big they're like each
each one was like eight foot tall i kind
of liked it but it's just like you said
it's a little bit distracting it's a lot
to live up to
but you don't want people to be looking
at that when you're doing stand up it's
not that they're like it's also
something about it where it's like a lot
to it's a it's a lot to live up to it's
like a celebration that you shouldn't be
celebrating at that moment right i don't
know right like just comedy you know
just do the comedy it was a lot it is a
lot of times we're laughing because
there's a lot and i also didn't like it
in a theater like i didn't like to me
like i feel my best when i'm in like a
small intimate like
la jolla yeah like addison's gonna be
great like i like the club
i like to feed off the but but i had a
thought the other day like comedies
really changed from my generation or
like as i was coming up because comedy
used to just be
like um it belonged to the guy who got
up there usually the guy
rarely the gal but the guy got up there
who was this total underdog who was
dressed shitty who just never and he got
up and he just was [ __ ] hilarious
like if you watched guys like dave attel
back in the day craig geraldo oh my god
sure and i'd be in new york and i'd
watch these guys yeah and they just get
up and they were just these sloppy dudes
who probably didn't take care of
themselves certainly certainly would
never
in any way self-promote they were the
anti-self promotions
still that way well yeah but now now
with this new generation and people like
yourself and this is a very smart thing
is the first time that guys like you
were at this actually at the spearhead
one of the guys do this now it's schultz
and these guys
who because of the internet we're able
to not only curate an audience but make
money and create a spectacle you have
you have shorts coming out there in a in
a robe that never would have been done
back there yeah never there's bruce
buffer right now joe coy's got a dj that
that [ __ ] is so
almost anathema to the old school comedy
it's up in the game right like everybody
year well now it's a it's a show it's
perspective yeah yeah and then you go to
the shelter's show like and
you know everybody knows i love [ __ ]
show it's like you go to a show i'm not
just saying it's like you've never seen
anything like it i'm back like the
closest one to do it like him is kevin
hart i bet you've never seen anything
like it dude it's it's not and there's
nothing it's not
and and for him the production value
like the amount of money he spends on
production he's like oh i'm not worried
about how much money i make as long as
the fans have a great show that's all i
care about yeah because because you know
i saw him like dude you must be you know
i know i'm like you must be spending how
much [ __ ] money a production it's
nuts yeah i'm sure it's like a mini
super bowl when you see a show yeah i i
uh like technically yeah really yeah
that's so that's so um
it's just so alien to me and no one will
leave there be like that you know that
wasn't a good show you're walking around
like holy [ __ ] remember nobody was
really making money too like it never
before the internet and podcasting even
established comics were never making tv
money some of them you know sometimes
you'd have like like that guy rodney
they'd be making you know but but for
the most part you were doing the clubs
you were doing local and that's what
that's why guys would do stand-up to get
to tv yeah and now it's like yes if my
agent goes hey man
it used to be you wanted to do a tv show
to get off the road because
now
you want a road you want podcasting in
the road it better be something super
special to get you out of that that's
right
but you've been getting up uh at laugh
factory right chris different places
yeah all over mm-hmm uh did you never
answer about the haha this week but
that's oh what did you say about the hop
i said come to us oh you're dead yeah
he's doing he's doing uh he's doing
improv
no i'm not guys i'm not doing it i'm not
right
i know i'm not want to drive down i'm
not and now i'm gonna surprise everybody
i'm not announcing any shows i'm not
doing anything
but i uh i do pop up yeah there's
another place called jamming van have
you ever been there particularly
i don't i don't do outdoor shows it's uh
there's outdoor and there's indoors oh
you'd like gemini but why don't you do
outdoor shows you just don't like it
you'd actually like it yeah this one's
different yeah no i know everyone's
gonna tell me they would invite me to do
it
i was gonna do a deal the other night
yeah it doesn't feel outdoors there's
something about it i really like what is
outdoor it is outdoor
there's no roof and it's outdoor you
know how you don't let blondes in your
show i don't do outdoors yeah
interesting yeah i'm an indoor cat
mm-hmm no blonde guys
no blondes i don't know not a lot of my
shows soy boys they're not allowed as
much no blondes no leather jackets no
you have leather jacket if you're brown
hair oh hell yeah but the thing is is uh
you can honestly if you're a blonde dude
you can wear a brown leather jacket but
not a black one no no
no
no no no no
no no no no
have you ever worn a suit ever
do you own a suit yeah you want to shoot
some of the uh i wear a suit yeah i wear
a suit uh at funerals i wear a suit uh
you have some first of all
right
first of all don't talk like this now
you're talking like this open your mouth
[Music]
i think you have a picture you're in a
suit and i'm in a button-up at one of
your premieres years ago like [ __ ]
eight nine years ago oh i think i drove
there by myself to support my friend
chris
oh brian you weren't there no i wasn't
it was probably a [ __ ] machine gun
what's that
when you when you destroy crowds no it's
during the day
no brian does day shows oh man
mayonnaise you [ __ ] you know who
crushes day shows is uh brick crasher
you know shows in the daytime i gotta
pee i'm gonna pee empire your big dick
oh i did gone in my pants
brian bring me back a [ __ ] steak
national chicken hot sandwiches man hey
kyle where where did we uh cater the
food from um
waffle love shout out to waffle love you
like nashville chicken hot sandwiches
chris hey don't never have to eat that
yeah and i'm not ashamed of it dude when
i say stuff i'm not insecure about it
i've never had a [ __ ] nashville hot
sandwich well here's getting just as
long as yours oh dude don't make it go
over the side like that i'm little
because of the reason how bad it looks
oh you you don't like emo think that
looks
horrid
put it back
or put the hat on nope dude that
you do look like a little nicky yep holy
[ __ ] i look like avril lavigne security
wait look that way let me see how it
looks that way wow dude
avril living security
wow that's amazing yeah thanks dude i
didn't know it was that long me neither
i put in a man but you put your hair in
a man-bun
as a yeah i've never done it like no
have you done it and like gone out i've
done yeah i've done in like done shows
really yeah
i'm a little self-conscious of it on
stage so i put a hat on right before i
go on dude i think you anyone should
never put do a man bun really yeah i i
don't think so just
well okay it looks sweet
well no honestly if you have really long
it looks sweet dude if you have really
long hair i don't like the way you're
sitting yeah i'm good with it though man
you know
too relaxed i'm just chill man yeah
you're a chill i'm very i think honestly
if you have really long hair then okay
you got to put it up sometimes but
you're younger than yours
way longer your hair is long is it is it
really long i mean it used to be longer
here's pretty long
let me look at it like you're just
getting a little popping daddy
you know i cut my own hair
oh wow yeah so brian
whoa
he uses a flowbee yeah it's [ __ ] i do
trims i i cut my hair and i do it all
um you like i do kind of every now and
then i just go i walk by the mirror i go
oh needs a snip
and then i just the back though you're
not like
i mean like you've got to cut yourself
and [ __ ] because you got long i don't
even know how to do that yeah i mean i
suppose it is layered because it's not
even yeah yeah
i'm just uh
around cool guys do you dye it you know
what i don't dye it i've never dyed my
hair once i did once i did once and
every single person in my life went
don't do that again well what did you
you dyed it just for men but but you
have grace they say jet black they mean
[ __ ]
okay so one of the things online that
people say to me is oh you dye your hair
don't eat that stuff no well no no no no
but i think that the reason is because
this is gray and this is not that they
think that i dye my hair and uh you woke
up like that but but but why
why would i dye my hair hair and
not my beard because the beard's
trickier
is it trick what do you mean it's
trickier number one
like brian did once look like i took a
[ __ ] marker and he's like don't tie
your beard so my friend told me to do it
i was like all right but didn't you dye
your hair too no i've never
he makes so much money has somebody go
well don't do that with your beard you
know what i know how bring that up i
know how this is what brian looked like
oh that's right right there yeah wow
look at the box under his legs oh that's
a lego he shot his face yeah i don't
know if i'm famous enough to say
something online and have you hear it
but but that box gotta go yeah dude dj
khaled that box
fat joe that dj khaled looks so much
better on the right there
does he you look so much better like
that i have some thoughts nah dude don't
lie
yeah
that looks so bad on the left
are you a lego he looks like you're like
it looks terrible it looks awesome dude
it looks like armor
dj khaled on the right that's some sexy
ass i would listen to the guy on the
right i mean look don't get me wrong
he's not good looking no no but does it
matter no you don't have courses does it
matter you know i used to have them i i
tried this i grew i went to italy i grew
a mustache
and a little goatee
and my dad
my dad went he looked at me like i never
forgot this he looked at me he goes
what's uh this about and i said let me
get this let me picture this yeah so
it's a full mustache then like the like
the flavor saver here got this and then
i got that disgusting look just this
bubble and then that i got this and this
now my dad it was great my father goes i
came back from italy oh my father goes
what's uh this and i said i'm just
beware it now and he goes like this and
i never forgot this he goes
he goes he looks me he goes
and i said what you don't like it and he
goes
it's not you that's fair and i know and
i [ __ ] i the way he shave it right
away i shaved it immediately i went you
know for my dad to do that
like that was just it's so weird he just
whispered it to me that he's not a
subtle guy and i went oh i'm gonna go
[ __ ] shave this off right
oh wow that's some [ __ ] yeah you know
and dune
[Laughter]
it's like that dude he said he used the
voice and you went in and you shaved it
you blacked out and you shaved it who's
the girl in dune she's great oh the the
uh
zendaya zendaya
she was also in
little foot i know small foot and you
should know this because you have a kid
wasn't she also in the greatest showman
yeah that's hugh jackman whoever said
she was
whoever said she was hey dude there
isn't a movie that i would watch less
than the greatest showman i've never
seen it and i will never see that and
it's crazy to know that there is a piece
of cinema out there that i will never
watch and it will just
i will die okay and it will never be
seen by it it doesn't cross my mind to
watch it it has its merits and isn't
wolverine in that singularity
got great music in it was it was
probably not wasn't it nominated i think
it was it's got very good musical you
like musical theater i do you do a
little music i do theater i do you can
say does this answer your question
you
do i do musical theater you do the math
oh that's nice that's really the way you
wow you held that vibrato
yeah yeah i didn't know zac efron was in
showman too he's not broken i didn't see
it yeah no desire
zero desire do you see her in euphoria
though
no oh i i feel like
drake produced it you never seen it he
did euphoria what is euphoria i don't
know that's about high school kids
basically doing drugs
oh yeah i heard it was my high school
experience was not like theirs i'll tell
you that much they're doing drugs
they're [ __ ] i've never done drugs
you haven't even drank never no i've
never done drugs and i uh but everyone
thinks you're on drugs right yeah oh
yeah yeah everyone thinks about drugs
you've not done any uh you never you
don't even drink wine no have you had a
glass of wine no never no how have you
not had a glass of wine
it's a beautiful thing did you think i
was giving you a tall boy when i gave
you this
no i know it like it's a waffle i know i
know it's water dude dude
i'm telling you i know what it is okay
okay don't please don't please don't
come at me aggressively like i don't
know what
it's liquid you're nervous i know what
liquid death is all right don't be so
[ __ ] why are you shaking dude
oh no it's not a tall
boy them
teased you drink secretly at night
ah no wonder you look so drawn do you
still drink beer be i never drink i do
drink beer never well i never use drink
beer now i drink beer because if i drink
red wine i'm old i i don't sleep well so
now i drink [ __ ] sapporo dude i had
two sapporos
how about how about when i'm going tough
mudder some guy goes dick boy
it's 9am yeah i'm there my son was
running before me because 9 am too early
here's a course dude i get a running
maybe he wanted you to open it for him
no he said here's a cold one here like
made it clear like here's a cold one
they said there's amino acids in there
yeah oh god and i went okay i'll drink
it and let's go pressure drink
it wow
nine in the morning probably if you're
wrong my kid goes what's that daddy
don't worry about it it's the carbs
yeah i i now i drink yeah it looks weird
on the right what'd you say yeah that's
a weird camera angle or that's just i
think it might be the giant tv chris
don't you've heard of
what nbc
like tnt and stuff yeah i i've heard of
tnt
bravo
honestly bravo is the worst [ __ ]
channel in the world okay i used to work
for them i don't okay well i liked your
stuff thank you
thank you that guy is on it where they
have all those fake shows where it's
like hey let's film every i know you can
you mean like the kardashians but
they're like hey let's film them do
stuff and then it's not that oh like
real housewives or something yeah and
then and but that show fine but then the
show that they have where they're like
let's catch up with them
a year later and that guy with the gray
hair is like so
oh andy cohen yeah so tell me
when you did this and then oh you
recapping
nothing
it is true dude it's true you know it's
weird i did his show that remember you
were out there filming the joker bean i
met you and the your small friend you
didn't tell me about was going to be
there at the bar which really threw me
for a doozy and remember i had to go to
the bathroom because i was laughing
anyways um i did this
well i didn't you didn't
was this not weird i i was filming uh
what was that show called chin with well
my buddy lee does not give a [ __ ] and
he's also hates when people treat him
differently okay
no hold on i filmed this show with andy
cohen big show brian goes i'm right up
the street dude i go i'm gonna get done
here i'll meet you for a drink it was
cool i go just you goes yep
watch the bar what watch what i was on
watch what happens live big show anyways
are you done with it no big deal yeah i
[ __ ] walk in not a big deal a huge
joke
anyways so i go to me brian big deal so
i go to meet brian there ryan doesn't
tell tell me if they went through
somebody for luke his friend's there the
the the small guy from the joker and i
told lee and i go deadly i said lee i go
i'm not telling him you're here because
lee hates this this we're walking down
the street and he's like watch this car
it's gonna stop for me they're going to
stop everybody then somebody gets up
there like hold the door open everybody
everybody treats you like you're but
he's a great guy and he's not as a great
guy great actor but he also dates the
[ __ ] really hot girls he's just a
[ __ ] brit who doesn't give a [ __ ] and
he's like watch this it's so annoying
that everybody stops and kind of treats
him differently instead of treating him
like a [ __ ] man which is what he is
and i said i said dele i go now brendan
doesn't know
that you're a small person and i'm just
going to have him come in and just let's
not have been fine i have no issues
small people but i walk him right guys
how you doing
and he knows what he's doing and lee
gets up and goes hey how you doing and
brendan goes
you know what you said what you went oh
wow
[Laughter]
and he was a great guy he's a great
great guy he's a fun night in new york
wow that was great a fun night that was
a good night i love we haven't done a
new york night man new york's been in a
[ __ ] show you know i'm trying i'm lining
up now no it's back now oh people doing
shows they're like chrissy d did but i'm
doing uh i'm trying to line up rhode
island i've never been to rhode island
i've always wanted to go yeah christy d
did some club out there he's like you
got to do it so i hit up justin so i
think i might go to rhode island in
february that's great i've never been
there i've always wanted to go like i
want to explore like the east coast
rhode island might be the last vestige
of the old school italians that's why
that's what i want the old school
italian mafia like that might be the
last the time hey rhode island yeah
hey
that's not really what they say hey
we're in the road have you performed
there everybody said i don't know i
never have really even back in the day
because i guess you fly into boston it's
a 40 minute drive yep that's all it is
which is great 100
this fight i'm really excited about this
fight do people tune in are they going
to be like oh you don't [ __ ] talk
about the fights should we or no no we
can't talk about cabbage hours this
fight
so just so you know this guy dan
hooker's a killer right yeah but he's
fighting
he's a fighter fighter he took this on
short notice yeah he's fighting he's
fighting the guy who's supposed to be
like the next the next
yeah short notice that's that's tough
right now chris that guy fights at 155
pounds oh wow now here's what else is
interesting is because uh when he lives
in australia and new zealand i always
get those two confusions because this is
the main fight i think it's new zealand
right you're two away isn't he out of
izzy's camp he's out of is he's camp so
because covert so strict there like one
person got coveted they lock everything
down they go around and his his training
camp whoever opened that should be fired
but uh in his training camp the cops
will come and shut down your training
camp so he had to basically do an
underground training camp
new zealand jesus and then it was a
nightmare he couldn't get a visa to fly
out so he tweeted out hey let the
whatever whoever the government know i'm
trying to get a visa to get out to fight
they bombarded the
the
new zealand government so much they had
to address it and gave him a visa and
time to fight this fight
who was his last fight it was a [ __ ]
barn burner and he was all bunched up at
the end of the fight who was his last
fight
that was a tough fight man
was it calvin
that's my son's name
uh he lost to chandler and that that was
like chandler's debut he lost a point
knocked him out yeah he's had some good
wins though man well i think it was
pourier and he lost to pueri right was
it he lost to pouring in chandler oh
this guy's a nightmare oh my god his
last point oh like a crazy name yeah
yeah
yeah did he win
yes
this dude is a and then then
i think this is gonna i think that's
cool when you do that yeah when you say
and so we're gonna do that i do that so
what i do it's like very like actual
right yeah because i'm i'm i'm i'm maybe
right hey remember early in the
broadcast you called me a wigger
wigger we got it yeah we still have a i
feel no i didn't say that i said you're
uh you i did not call you that i did no
chris you were here no yeah i mean say
no with the a and then
this guy's a nightmare
whoa that's actually cool yeah
um so that's what i'll do sometimes too
okay so sometimes you go yeah this guy's
a nightmare can you ever sing it with
the nanette is that too much what's that
man
i wanna ride i do that sometimes too i'm
gonna rock
yeah that's good it's nice when i get
off stage and [ __ ] the crowds going
[ __ ] nuts which they always do
thank you very much i did it all tonight
you know i did that and i got more so
and what about backpacking
so wait so and that that's a lot to say
at the end like in that rock style voice
and and and then what do they do when
you do that they go i've i haven't been
to a [ __ ] rock and roll maybe do they
ever go oh
and then well you do more and then i
come back out and i go you think i was
done [ __ ] the whole time in the
singing voice yeah well wow yeah yeah
that's really impressive and then you go
on and do more comedy or what what's
that so so then after that you do more
comedy i do you're just at maples like
that smaller room you do this that's off
the hook i'll probably do it where i'll
go you guys ready for improv now and
they go and i go guess what and they go
what they're still saying i go this last
hour you desire and they're like that
was [ __ ] improv they're like what the
hell really and then i launched into my
[ __ ] it's not your stuff
really oh yeah and then how long do you
do a material as long as i [ __ ] won
what because i got that much two hours
really about two hours sure carlos
so it's a three-hour show ain't nobody
getting up to go to the bathroom really
so what if they really have to go
you don't want to miss oh okay i
understand what if they really need to
go bring one of those long tennis ball
cans and fill it up with [ __ ] oh no wow
no people don't have to say [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i got a [ __ ] in a tennis
ball kid no i mean i guess you could i
mean some people have to [ __ ]
in your show you're going for three
hours right yeah you might have to [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i eat a big bowl of
[ __ ] sketti before i go see comedy i
do teddy and [ __ ]
two of these i drink two of these i
drink a big bowl of [ __ ] spaghetti
and i sprained my usually [ __ ] like 30
minutes in but you're gonna do three
hours three hours so i got a [ __ ] in one
of those pen no tennis balls a salinger
tennis ball a [ __ ]
poo poo puma do they do it yeah tennis
balls
what the [ __ ] dude corks i'm going to
spray spray and i'm sitting you know
what you should do what is just [ __ ]
get the tennis ball can you insert it in
your anus yeah and this way your [ __ ]
it's still inside you but you already
went yeah right and then when you're
done and when you're like you know got
that what do you do i go that's it for
me and i'm a guy and i'm like wow that
was amazing and i [ __ ] waddle out to
my car and grab the top yep
and then put the top on it toss it i go
home [ __ ] none the wiser that's right
you got to sell those tennis ball cans
as merch oh
that's a good idea yep bring cans all
right here we go here we go i got money
on coms out brandon has money on on dan
hooker well i'm sorry i mean
i'm sorry
racist it's not my yeah there's a tad
racist racist all good yes called me but
you know brandon said
brandon said dan hooker it's a better
fight than i think people get hookers oh
half guard
i mean don't get me wrong it's a tall
task for hooker also shorter camp
it's a [ __ ] nightmare man it's also
this guy's
supposed to fight uh dos anjos
yeah what does he do here please oh it's
i mean you got a dagger standing blanket
on you that's that's a problem and he's
comfortable just kind of hanging you're
wearing that blanket and it's not warm
and it's not the problem is if you just
stay here and you don't finish like
khabib did you're not going to win a lot
of fans and you're not going to get the
title shot you're going to just
you got to go for you have to do some
work daddy yeah hmm that's interesting i
never thought of that yeah no i really
mean it no yeah yeah you got to be kind
of a little flashy entertaining you
can't be uh just a grinder no like a
john fitch type of vibe where you're
just taking guys down there i ask you a
question if this guy just this guy on
the top here yeah if he just
leaned up and go and goes
and his spits on him yeah that you can
do that in the new year
no there's no spinning the street you
can got it
dude you can do anything all right yeah
okay
you just farted you're not gonna blame
that on me you just farted on the
leather chair he's doing some wings
he's winking at me farted that's crazy
you just winked up are you gonna blame
it on me oh he's going for a camaro here
but you farted he's cranky oh oh wow
well this will get you down shot a
camaro no oh it's bad oh god that's
[Music]
now here's the thing about hooker so he
went through all that trouble dude
no but through all the trouble in new
zealand not seeing his family all that
[ __ ] is that khabib hugging him there
yeah yep khabib's in this corner this
could be his brother i know yeah and
that was so impressive god damn it dude
it's just a matter of time for that boy
gets to the top i know because that i
mean the way he dismantled hooker which
isn't easy to do [ __ ] not now you got to
fight the lights of chandler daichi you
know poirier yeah it's not a tell me
charles oliveira beats him maybe
i don't think so not a chance no i just
lost 14 million dollars
wow chris 14 what you put 14 mil on
hooker chris why didn't you talk to me
payout was going to be good i know dude
but you should 14 million oh no
i feel bad i like the bed though
i'm gonna throw up i didn't know you had
that much money in the bed oh god it's
all of it
he's cute though yeah he's 18 or 19.
it's kind of weird
yeah you think he's in the chicks i hope
i thought he was five or six guys
no he's not five or six guys i don't i
honestly dude i don't give a [ __ ] about
that person at all
dude that was brian he keeps going like
this he would go i can't believe he did
that and he goes
no it wasn't me dude there's no way
anybody could tell that it was me and
i'm saying it was brian 18 dude
he's 18.
i was a genetic disorder called dwarfism
wow well i thought of something
different than that yeah i know it's
like gives them a childless appearance
with a small height and high pitch voice
all right well god bless them now
what's their average uh lifespan though
i don't know it can't be long they've
all over done another week they've seen
the tiny they live over 300 you've seen
a tiny bit
they're the longest lived people poor
dan hooker yeah what are you gonna do
though what the [ __ ] why poor dan hooker
well he's a little bit like cowboy right
where he's you you you call him up he's
gonna take the fight but it sometimes
has to be a business decision there
where
he's doing that with bad matchups then
you get out of the race but here's the
thing also you realize in your heart
you're never going to be a champion as
long as that guy's there that's the
problem you always realize no matter
what you're very lost
already you lost your channel already so
yeah
holy [ __ ] bro sorry that guy's 18 19.
imagine you're just somebody that
everybody picks up oh it's true i would
you know what i would do i would [ __ ]
i would have worked i would wear weights
in your pocket
that says don't touch me nah bro you're
thinking inside the box both of yours
okay let's get outstanding this is what
you do okay
you never
use
bathrooms you don't go to public
restrooms you don't use the restrooms at
home you just wait you wait until
someone does that [ __ ] thing where
they pick you up
and if it's forward you piss in their
face
and if it's out to the world but you can
piss you [ __ ] on their [ __ ] piss in
your pants bob no
no because you have a flap you train
[Music]
this is awesome i have a great idea you
tie it here and it's a flap and you
bring it under
over your shoulder like this so you have
a [ __ ] pulley a tassel right yeah and
somebody picks you up and you go
right in their [ __ ] face they'll
learn quickly
unless
that's what they're saying about no
we've seen dwarves out no no no no have
you ever seen a tiny grandpa yeah
dwarves live longer longer no they don't
dude i hope they do the longest living
was 94 years
that's forever yeah well whoa
hey kyle just sent me this what a
nightmare
what oh that's chris
all right that's chris
i [ __ ] knew it thank you reuben
that's my
oh nice wow that's really awesome that's
really good yeah avoiding covet it's
actually kind of cool all you forgot was
a mcdonald's coffee in there yeah
i um oh it says life reps that's
hilarious
he's really good yeah that's good i can
uh you need to have that for merch i'll
do that and also the hair does look like
i cut my own hair so that's good hey did
you know chris cuts his own hair
uh i cut my own hair yeah yeah all right
yeah you're losing a little bit huh
you're getting uh
see they're picking them up again dude i
know
well i mean they kind of have to for the
photo it's gonna be so low you know no
you just zoom the camera out dude or you
just [ __ ] everyone else has got to
sit down it lies down on their stomach
everybody gets down to me
it's on their stomach
i mean i just feel bad for the guy i
didn't know he was i had no idea ooh our
five thousand dollar bets up next or two
thousand sorry five thousand peter young
corey san hagen what you want to read
you wanna you wanna you wanna pull back
pull out corey i'll give you a chance to
pull out nope
all right
i'm nervous over here mr [ __ ] nervous
okay it's gonna let you no no no no no
if i go take a piss are you guys gonna
not gonna set tbn networks on fire can
you guys hold the four down hard we can
hold the fourth down you gotta go to the
bathroom yeah
bro i'm not joe rogan i can't hold her i
know he's amazing bro it's ridiculous he
pisses his pants
no he has a bag that's attached to him
yeah just don't spit that rumor people
like ah
i mean who would believe that he [ __ ]
well people believe anything
they believe he has a bag if you said
seriously you know he has a bag people
would buy it yeah
you know he's back he's back i know he
has a bag i've seen it yeah i've seen
his pistol yeah it's got i think you
should send it too yeah all i've read it
just was like that
i'm gonna pee before the co-main event
you guys look at this bro are you
kidding me because i know you you're not
used to a lot of this like now that
guy's 170. that guy fights at 170. how
the [ __ ] does he suck down the 170.
that's crazy look at him yeah now he's
got his hands full now he's got his
hands full because he's not going to
wrestle comes out well we find colby now
i know that i'm saying
i know that you go he just beat a guy
not the time i understand but he's not
going to wrestle comes out he could yeah
i don't think so see you dude
see you later buddy
he never comes back he never comes he'll
sit in silence till he comes back all
right
dude honestly yeah
[ __ ] subscribe to my youtube channel
[ __ ] this what the [ __ ] hey does this
make you want to train harder now chris
train harder no dude subscribe to my
[ __ ] youtube channel dude don't use
this as a commercial it's just like for
you dude how many people are watching 17
18. yeah go over and [ __ ] subscribe
to my youtube channel and listen to my
podcast dude please man you're welcome
it's called congratulations i don't know
you know it's called congratulations
okay
i'm sorry
i talk about all the hard-hitting issues
on my podcast you do yeah like what i
mean whatever's going on in the world
man yeah give me so what is going on in
the world give me your come here give me
the news
if somebody said chris tell us what's
going on in the world so it's crazy
first of all yeah right because covet is
just the way everything happened with
the lockdown and then yeah and then and
then uh people were just like okay well
let's see let's ride this out for a
little bit where where there's masks and
[ __ ] and then you're being generally no
no
new york had a big outbreak and then you
know and then they were saying l.a was
kind of leading the ring and i was like
ellie was like well there were the masks
and then it was man you're doing
right what's going on now yes so i'm
getting to it you got to go backstory so
[ __ ] people are invested then when i
hit you with the now [ __ ] people are
like oh okay i get it but we all get
that so now what's going on now give us
an assessment of what you think
america's standing and give us some
insight in foreign policy and politics
so look it's diverse but what you're
gonna say is you're gonna say is okay
but why is it diverse and i'm i'm gonna
be like okay what's different people
no matter what issue you have in america
yeah
it is legitimate they split 50 50 down
the middle right so you have that so you
have you so you have trump you have
biden now trump isn't the president
anymore obviously
i know but this is the back story but
okay so trump isn't president anymore a
lot of people voted for him
and a lot of people so and abide as a
president a lot of people voted for yeah
maybe more people some people think the
election was rigged yes we all know so
some people think the electorate right
so what is your prediction for the
midterm elections okay so
first the republicans
yes first of all it's wild yes what so
first of all it's wild what's what
because everybody thinks no matter what
candidate you have yeah there's gonna be
50 50.
yeah no not everybody thinks it's gonna
be 50 50. no no no i'm saying no matter
what happens everyone's gonna go
fifty-fifty no that's not right boring
hey yeah thank you you guys talking
about the santa's point
no no not the santa's 20-24 you eat a
donut are you eating cheese well
whatever it is you sound exactly the
same as you do when you don't have that
in your mouth come on chris
chris sorry chris man don't he's
sensitive about him but no it's okay but
we got to rip each other but
when you don't have a doughnut no chris
don't you been practicing no
no man listen i'm going to ask you again
okay okay we're talking about desantis
[Laughter]
wow
uh yeah we were talking about the santa
switch 24. he might do it
florida has been crushing it
yeah and what crushing it how with the
lowest covered rates oh yeah didn't do
it
they already they blew it out they got
it and they're like [ __ ] it and now
they're just like dude i was down there
in the height of the pendant
nothing no math nothing yeah no they
don't give a [ __ ] it's crazy yeah that's
right
boy there's batman you live in a bubble
i dude i don't i'm not
i'm not
a [ __ ] covet boy dude
no dude i don't wear masks in [ __ ]
situations where no one's wearing a mask
it's annoying as [ __ ] i don't like when
people are just like
when there's one person with a mask on
it's like
we're all not wearing it you're gonna
get it
you're gonna get it if you're the only
one here just go home
you know i do have a mask and i tell you
what dude there's people who talk closer
now because they want to prove to you
right yeah and it's just like dude get
out of my face anyway even pre-cove it i
don't want you that close yeah i don't
want you that close now you see that guy
right there yeah he's a [ __ ] bitter
yarn and he's gonna he's rushing 35
pounds
i've known him since he was 16. yep so
you're going to root for him very good
sure i root for him
unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately this that was my first
coach there christian allen now is now
he has a man bun is this the main
fight his man does is this this is the
coming of that this is the main fight
this is and that's the one before the
main one yes i don't like how many there
are yeah there's five that's too many no
no you'd like like two i want one and i
want the rounds to be 30 minutes each
five rounds oh that'd be fun long time
chris
yeah why are you arbitrarily deciding
that like that's just kind of what i do
that's my brand but guys a human body
can't really take decisions
they pass the [ __ ] out and then someone
wins and then
they bring a pillow or something i don't
know they take breaks they [ __ ] eat
sandwiches in the middle oh man throw it
all up bro how much better would that be
no eating meals and fighting [ __ ] that
i'm starting that yeah
russia they're doing it meals and fights
uh
christian allen is is a savant yeah yeah
monster and a ninja yeah a ninja yeah
he's like i'm going to go get whatever
was in your mouth right now but i'm
going to talk so loud and still be here
that you guys are going to [ __ ]
you're going to get a doughnut you're
going to get cheese what oh cool
he [ __ ] up the whole backdrop
yeah way to go chris
uh-oh
oh we got their cheese daddy's plate
well there's some good cheese and some
batches on there right that's really
good is it nice man you're you're you're
very you look like a skater you're
dressed you're very dusty looking this
is an off-white
that's not an off-black i'm off black
oh you're saying oh is that all
expensive is that expensive gear
probably more than one
don't be obnoxious that what do you mean
you don't know
the last thing i heard
before this was mine yeah was
will you wear this
please
oh so you didn't pay for it
just don't stick yourself wow
[ __ ] your offensive listen mm-hmm just i
asked you
the best piece of cheese on there chris
can you wrap in the salami for me daddy
sure i will
so
the last thing i heard don't eat it in
an annoying way no i won't
last thing you heard no i won't because
i'm a man of my word
yeah
last thing i heard yeah
before i wore this yeah the first time
was yeah
will you wear this please
[Laughter]
so i don't know how much it is
shoot with your mouth closed you [ __ ]
it's
you're so obnoxious dude
so i guess somebody wanted you to wear
it because oh yeah then when you get the
brown down
yeah here we go
and then
do you know what they said after i put
it on
what man the first thing i heard yeah
when this was
in my possession yeah
are you going to rap on those first what
dude
is hungry chris don't no i know but all
right don't eat that i'm saying the
first thing i heard when this was in
my possession what
thank you
he's so stupid
chris
so gross you know there are cameras on
you you can't
eat like that
why are you putting it all the way in
the back of your mouth you're not a
[ __ ] snake you're not a snake you
have teeth you can you don't have to
put it all the way in the back it's
hitting the gang of your
doppelganger whatever [ __ ] that thing's
called
oh man i hate when people eat slow like
that
well they don't want me wrapping yours
now with all the [ __ ] salad
oh look at this guy peter young what a
[ __ ]
i don't even eat so he would be in jail
this guy would be this guy would be in a
maximum look at that
he'd be in a what
he'd be in a what he'd be in a maximum
security prison i think if he didn't
have a case
is it no i don't mean it that way he's
just violent maybe a nice guy
i'm sure he's a nice guy but he's
very in
i don't mean that i don't mean he's a
criminal i just mean he's a badass
yeah that cheese is [ __ ] nice
i forgot i told my buddy i was gonna
[ __ ] have lunch with him and
he was like
when are we going look what he's that's
a real calendar look what he's doing
sterling look what he's doing
picking him up tripping him i mean jesus
christ oh man
now kyle have you had these uh nashville
chicken hot sandwiches
they're nice yeah where are are they
here they're coming here oh you got it
okay little and i thought that's all
right
this goes five rounds i don't like yeah
i just stuff it in the back there yeah i
know man
now you i you've had the uh my my
friends at al's hot chicken how's it
compared to that [ __ ]
all these names the hot chicken names
the best chicken sandwich in l.a kevin
yeah kevin said that all these names
with the chicken sandwiches it's always
like al's hot chicken or like [ __ ]
steve's hottest chicken yeah
what would you what would you call it
birds r us
you like that bird's arrest sounds tasty
i thought let's see spitballing ideas
here birds are uh you have just
different kinds of birds you know do you
have a vulture just a vulture all birds
you come to my cold vulture
sloppy i've got i've got birds that
don't even really i've got an extinct
[ __ ]
dodo bird sandwich
you want dodo bird stew bald eagle
breasts
[ __ ] that's illegal yeah
you know they shut down that [ __ ] uh
this this sushi place called hump
and and uh
they were selling whale meat and they
were selling a dolphin for real for [ __ ]
where uh
at the santa monica airport in
l.a who's eating dolphin meat at the
santa monica airport was it like the
secret menu like how in and out does it
they had something to say
sea turtle
sea turtle maybe
i swear i got it you can eat sea turtles
santa monica airport [ __ ] off out of
santa monica airport brian had a dream
and thought it was real dolphin
many times brian had a dream and thought
it was real it was all great brian had a
dream and thought it was really humped
dude
singer brian's big enough to be [ __ ]
don't even google it we all know it's
fake we don't even have to google it put
hump restaurants i love when people say
[ __ ] you know it's false you don't even
need to google it google it right with
your finger no don't don't put sea
turtle just do restaurant hump i don't
think there's a restaurant called hump
you know what dude i don't think there's
a restaurant that's what i'm saying in
santa monica that's how much you're
lying brian you made this up
look up i'm fine i just spit type in
hump restaurant i know shut down i mean
knows what to do
yeah but he's just like flying
you know yeah he's high
no my computer has viruses
on heroin see it's not working
chin's on methamphetamine
seal how about this literally sealed uh
whale do you keep gaming animals and i
don't believe you there it is
condors look at this look at this found
selling whale meat closes a sushi
restaurant called the hump
that federal prosecutors found was uh
way too long why would they be doing
well
let's close its doors why were they
doing that though wow that's on new york
times
it's been in japan hey you ever had
whale full of america so this is the
main mercury no co-main event god damn
it this is exciting this is me and
brennan have two thousand dollars on
this i got the russian guy right this
boy corey yeah
i'm biased i love this kid see aurora
that's my hometown i didn't know if you
knew that you had to go with you had to
go with court you have to you got it you
got to go down with it that's guy
killing whales
why though is the demand that high but
also just serve tuna but that's what i'm
saying like what what the [ __ ] is the
demand there was a demand obviously oh
yeah really yeah have you ever eaten a
whale
no no no no don't got humpback when i
was in the yakuza when i was in the
store
oh god
it actually looks pretty nice though
i'll give you that yeah that's the way
yeah but it's full of mercury
oh shut up all right
mercury like out of tuna yeah give me a
[ __ ] break lead mercury you don't
want to eat hey brian that happened
that happened 11 years ago dude i know
oh brian's bringing up [ __ ] like it's
news
you guys heard of napoleon
[ __ ] bringing up [ __ ] you hear that
mafia guy got shot at a restaurant in
new york all right you know what are we
doing dude guys i'm just saying
this is a big fight for corey
it's a title shot you know it's so weird
to me when somebody has no tattoos but a
huge backpack too
it's so weird what am i doing next where
are you getting your next tattoo on his
neck i bet not telling shh
only i know i can't stand when people
take something that's not mysterious and
make it a mystery like we're all waiting
with better brothers
what you're gonna get on your [ __ ] since
you got the worst tattoos to begin with
a plane
a general plane dude and then a [ __ ]
eagle with fire coming oh dude you know
what the weirdest [ __ ] thing is what
you made me think of this
you're a piece of [ __ ]
is that crazy no don't say that no i'm
not
you [ __ ] listen to me right now and
you're here in front of me and i'll come
at you but it's the other day we were
talking the other day we were talking
and in the middle of our conversation we
were facetiming and you stopped you
paused and you looked at me and you went
like this and if you've been in front of
me i would have punched you in the face
you looked at me and you went like this
you go
hey
you suck
out of nowhere
and i was like what the [ __ ] and no i'm
not i don't i don't wear that tattoo he
did he did this one remember the the guy
he went to uh yeah in prison yeah he did
he actually i know he i think he got out
he was in jail
it was like involuntary i guess because
he drove drunk in a mclaren like
crashing a phone pole
the most talented guy i've ever
his [ __ ] was he still doing tattoos or i
don't know i don't know i should
probably text him that [ __ ] yeah
he did this in like an hour
so oh wow yeah now you're setting you up
with them
yeah i've talked to him before yeah he's
just working great daniel daniel silva
yeah monster yeah he's great handsome
kid
um he's doing out of his house in the
hills and then killed that kid on
youtube
well the kid was from youtube not on
youtube they don't don't drink and drive
for god's sake
sorry everybody
don't drink don't drive hey take back
what you just said about me no no what i
was gonna say though is um i [ __ ] you
not no [ __ ] uh so i got this because
it's the tired eagle joke i make on the
[ __ ] man on fire on now that's a
peacock though yeah no this is an eagle
let me see dude this is
but but it's not a tired eagle that's
that eagle's on fire and let me see
because the special is a man on fire
no no my newest one is this one here the
uh
calvin i [ __ ] forget no it's uh
jesus i don't even know where it is
hold on i don't know where this guy's
hold on go to commercial i
was over here carefully
what is it airplane a paper plane yeah
just a paper plane another plane just
once you're in the plane
yeah i didn't realize that i got so many
flight cameras i want to get a blues
angel
no so damn it
whoops let me put this so um yeah
what was i saying oh yeah oh calvin
looked at it and he says
i swear to god and he says not that and
he every time he points he says that and
i don't [ __ ] know why i'm not even
joking because the joke
with a sharp beak what would you be b
you think
[Music]
like just in cities that was enron right
enron no not enron that was the exxon
they bought all those houses in florida
they have that rule where you can't take
their property oh they still have them
really they're in prison but nice houses
oh look at this this is a [ __ ] more
you know bp spill uh
why did i say enron
uh this is gonna be sound similar here
we go
this is an exciting fight chris you're
going to see a high level fighting here
you are good at one thing one thing is
for sure corey sandhagen you are going
to see an exciting fight now why would
corey uh san hagan only get a huge back
tattoo and no other tattoos that's uh
honestly only something that corey
sanhagen knows but the way he trots
around he looks ready and boy i'm
excited callan what do you think i think
that his skin tone you know it's funny
because
you gotta you're not allowed to do that
tonight what do you think i think that
at the end of the day corey sandhagen as
good as he is is going to lose to peter
young and i'm gonna
peter yan is an absolute monster for his
statue five
seven point five weighed 135 pounds
he is not
looking like a monster but let me tell
you he is one now
he is missing an e in his first name
it's okay
basically it doesn't matter because it
still sounds pure there he goes another
goes he's just shadow boxing now if that
were against someone that would be
devastating
right but he's not he's just kind of
punching the wind yeah here we go
look at how much taller
so you think you're going to go to the
atm
right after we
are going to do i'm going to i'm going
to unfortunately i'm i'm sorry that your
boy your boy bit off that's your boy
who's your boy that's that's right i'm
really close with him oh really
unfortunately and i think he's awesome
unfortunately peter young is a nightmare
every time you say someone's a nightmare
they lose yeah they do thank god i still
want to those guys in the back market
jeff one
no you'll see
all right well i'm rooting for your dude
thank you sir yeah
and i also gave him the nickname the
sandman so be cool
yeah
and that's what they call them yep oh
really cool
i give i want to give you guys he walked
in the gym at six he walked into our gym
at 16 just played basketball had no
experience now he's fighting for a world
title wow but you bet against him brian
you piece of [ __ ] i had to bet against
him i'm gonna
come up with a nickname for somebody and
then it's going to go crazy nuts like
that one day peter yan is a nightmare
right pro pewdier
pewdiepie
peter
i feel like
i feel like mark norman gave me my the
he gave me the thick one because he
called me thick crust
oh he kind of start the nickname boy can
you call me thick crust i'll give that
crap right you've had a lot of nicknames
i don't remember honestly
that was when i was fighting that's
different big brown's a good one i i
don't remember who gave me the nickname
of savior but there's
somebody yeah oh you know what's fun you
know what you want a funny origin story
of brian's nickname the kid what he made
it up yeah i know i know that i can't
give it to you because i know that you
dude you've been doing that forever uh
hey hey you were the kid your boy your
boy is very busy here your boy's very
busy he's gonna finish him dude he kind
of oh he dropped everything to fight
though he's not that busy
oh jesus he's just he's just more
dangerous dude
he's kicking his legs
wow interesting so you know like camaro
post that because they train together
and i watched them train together oh you
did yes wow it's always so [ __ ] i know
it's devastating but it's so [ __ ] when
guys do leg kicks it looks silly
no no it is no i see what you're saying
though yeah it always looks like they're
going huh i think the biggest [ __ ] move
is when they do the front knee kick well
that isn't that's really kind of like a
no-no right i mean i know they i know
they do it no i know but it's isn't it
like frowned upon not really oh really
the problem is you're close people's
[ __ ] christmas that peter p3 is going
to close distance here and it's going to
be okay if i do this
great body shot i poke i'm respectful
don't touch gloves
why not ah going for the kill you know
um
god one of these shots i would just
jesus
nine months
hitting him in the body man i'm
surprised uh peter keeps on trying to
take him down
the reach difference is a real struggle
for peter young right now he's got to
get close yeah
daddy
that's we call that money in the bank
money in the bank what because that oh
oh damn
now he's catching us on his hands no
that's definitely hurting
oh
oh [ __ ] yeah it's in tight
oh
now if he could just jump on there and
get his back that'd be fantastic god i
want to dress like those guys in the
back
where oh yeah yeah what do you call them
we call them some business
phobes
oh yeah but what what's what's ooh good
bodyguard i'm just saying what brian's
saying but what what what what's the
actual title that they have because you
know i'm a lord i've told you that you
are what was the deal with that what are
you talking about dude so my mom was
born raised in england and somebody
bought me land and to be a lawyer why
did you think why did you take why why
do you say this is a bad fight for peter
you're interrupted because because he's
he's very stationary as far as pressure
straightforward boxing oh okay and corey
is a nightmare to deal with with that
he's kicking his feet and if he knows
what you bring to the table he's gonna
be able to he's just a lot to get
through for 25 minutes congratulations
podcast on youtube
congratulations subscribe to my channel
congratulations smash that like button
kroy's fighting's very well smash that
like button do you want me to let you
out of the bet nope no all right i still
got it i got to stick to my bet bubba i
bet you knocked him out with a kicker
and this is what he knocked out with the
kicker this is where you know more about
fighting which makes me angry but oh you
thought you knew more no no no but i
just this is me with your money
are you going to do that with me
i guess that's cool no i'll probably buy
it you're quietly coming i'm going to do
with it chris buy some new shoes dude
what do you want the mummies what are
you thinking dude i'm pissed at the
mummies all right oh i'm so annoyed
still
this is hard for me to i can't talk
right now
it's just the first round but you know
peter young he starts slow a little bit
yeah he does he does but it's bad if
you're a pedogram fan and he's on his
heels yeah he doesn't i agree and he's
getting caught he's a pressure fighter
now cory's very white like chris so when
you land a jab it's going to show red
stink is [ __ ] pinky some guys get pink
as [ __ ] we call them pink dolphins oh
[ __ ] there's a kick for from oh
wow this is a [ __ ] yes
man that takedown is not there but i
like that he's mixing it around he's got
dagustani hips peter young well he's
from russia yes he is yeah yeah but he's
still going to sign him no i say he's
got i call him there's no doughnut hips
there nope i know
he wrestles different countries look at
that wow oh so baby see these little
babies bubba come on now
that hurts too oh
did he get him jumping knee yeah landed
oh jesus that's what he's doing san
diego is a [ __ ] nightmare now you bet
against him oh it's all pink as [ __ ]
look at his pick of [ __ ] yeah pink
dolphin there yeah why are you saying
dolphin it's a brand pink dolphin oh so
that's stuck in my mind
but dolphins aren't pink are they now
who's this camera where's where does
john fight out of you're hear of russia
okay
peter i'm sorry i'm saying his name
you guys guys guys
guys it's peter
yeah they should toss another e chris
now in a bit of a genius you wore the
halloween kicks on chris that's cool i
did i wore them because it's halloween
yeah no dude that's chris that's
christian allen's protege creation
correct since day one molded him it's
like you and chris yeah like chris cory
san hagen you're a christian allen yeah
dude that's how it starts you know chris
allen gave me a little boxing lesson and
i took one thing he taught me and went
back to my gym and
i did real well
you know what it was it went like
oh what's this it's called
fob
it says thob or thobe
i thought i thought i had a cooler name
but what's their titles like if i want
to be one of them what's what's the
title
can i do it
i've seen people do it because
you would wear it in the desert you
would that's how you conserve and
fighters would visit saudi arabia and
they would they would wear it and it's
like it's like a
traditional thing like this it looks
respectable this is a [ __ ]
attack look at him look at the way he's
right
look at the way he's [ __ ] this is a
high level people are like oh my god i
can't believe you're on there on tv i
was texting him my son he's cute oh
what's going on with him he's just being
cute yeah he's watching
is he what yeah he's fighting
he's there
yeah i'm already he's like do you think
that jan or sandhya is going to win
how old is he now
sandag uh i'm sorry
oh
the peons get ooh
them boys are throwing they are thro
throwing
corey made some adjust adjustments since
the tj fight he's not going up his back
he's not doing those weird granby rolls
he actually got peter younes back yep
he's young man
you got tattoo at that box those pot
boxing yeah that bums me out i'm not
gonna lie he's my boy that boxing tattoo
buns me out yeah i have a football with
a crown on it so i don't know how much
to say though oh damn that [ __ ] body
shot oh
you ever thought about getting your
tattoos removed chris no i honestly like
them still see you know why though
you know why though cause you got it
when you were older yeah yeah yeah yeah
football with the crown i got one oh
[ __ ] right right right i didn't have
money yeah so like some guy named larry
did it you know
did it was his name his name was larry
wow they cost me 200 knowledge i never
know a guy named larry period i've never
met a larry in my life so for that guy
200.
that'd be my advice to myself if he
wants to get tattoos with you older than
you that money dude
ah or just because you're gonna regret
it yeah yeah yeah because like what
you're into now yeah you're gonna do it
yeah yeah but you can be on your arm
yeah
yeah true so impressed with cory right
now i'm so impressed
it's just stylistically it's tough man
what uh tattoos
those are tough too when you get them
while you're young but for so you have
ones that you you would maybe uh oh i
mean carl they just they just remind you
of that right
i don't regret it yeah yeah i just wish
it was like god there's such better
artists yeah like especially the space
it consumes oh my god i could do
something so much doper now
but that pace that space is taken
damn just have something like prime real
estate you know yeah go go have someone
go over it make it better
have a like call larry back up that
never maybe he's better now that never
works out though when you cover him i
don't know dude cory's saying hey
[ __ ] pete davidson's getting all his
tattoos removed i heard it's miserable
no yeah he's getting all over look at
how red of course san higgins bodies wow
i could help
i'd pepper you up just like that chris
you'd be so red you'd look like you had
a sunburn they'd be like you've been in
the sun you'd go no i'm running it's
actually a disadvantage when you're that
white and you should because the judges
see that yeah but you don't see like if
peter was that white you'd see his
entire body be like a lobster but look
at cory's look at corey's defense he's
got [ __ ] crate
so it's a disadvantage you think because
of the oh yeah the judge you know judges
suck dude so they say that and they're
like oh he's
oh cory's landing more but because he's
red or like some guys like older
fighters have scar tissue so they cut or
swell easier but doesn't mean
dude don't blink chris don't blink
because you don't know okay okay
you know i see this spinning punch [ __ ]
a lot like this is the diaz bro this
one's spinning [ __ ] that [ __ ] really
works huh
sometimes yeah
but i mean yeah like when it lands and
people get now peter young trains out of
singapore actually he's muay thai no no
not at all no check that out brian say
more stuff that isn't true i think it's
true i do i think he's trying to stuff
about the whales before but his camp's
out of rush
and i don't like that i like that he's
switching oh [ __ ] uh oh no there's
nothing there okay i'm such a sucker for
ads in the ring oh crypto calm i should
get that oh sorry
[ __ ] [ __ ] i want to watch the fight oh
brian oh brian pitch chris on your no
fun toast oh dude sorry hold on
chipping lines i gotta go to the [ __ ]
note there's some still some of the no
fun toys left nfc you know you waste
your money yeah no no listen we uh we're
we sold a lot of them no we didn't
they're going like hotcakes
what what are you talking about tesla
and no fun his friends hustle them into
bikes
no they're actually hustled us but
they're actually selling well how much
your money make
well nothing yet yeah oh well that
sounds promising no but in like you have
it's a slow burn you said yes so maybe
it'll happen nfts aren't though you know
they're quick i don't know i told you i
said i said we started laughing about
that's what that's what other way are
portable proteins oh [ __ ] no i got a p3
i got a [ __ ] fight
god damn it i'm so such a sucker for the
monster underneath this thing oh i'm so
thirsty for monster energy distracting
boy he does come straight forward
doesn't he be peter yeah
these fighters came to play
one of them pinker than the other but
what's interesting is the body shots
[Music]
it's any man's game at this point
one-on-one
peter yohn is somebody you don't mess
with and in the middle of the rounds
they're going to put refrigerator
magnets on his face
just to make sure he is not a
refrigerator no chris that's not so far
they haven't let go up it turns out he's
not okay so he's not magnetic he is not
a refrigerator
there keeps the other guy they're
keeping the swelling down corey
chris who do you have in this fight
it's one man i don't
know
and that's that
i wasn't saying your chest brian you
were cory uh corey beats me by just a
couple inches
i will say though jan is so gifted when
it comes to making adjustments and i'll
also say what a great display of mma
striking by dude and san diego is
controlling the range and pace
beautifully dude there's not a bitter
cuck move to try and get on the ufc
broadcast by tweeting like man thank you
dana for this amazing fight card hashtag
ufc 267. oh oh caught him there
theo i do is a joke which is hilarious
and they always post it oh really yeah
always what's he saying he'll be like
man this is about to be a barn burner
ufc 267 he always gets on there
that's my special [ __ ] spin kicks are my
specialty
he's getting caught man he's getting
[ __ ] caught who's getting caught
peter yeah yeah this is a good one
i knew you'd like this chris no this
one's a good one i knew you'd like this
wait till the next one too dude yeah the
next two are [ __ ] great fights
there's two more one more no no this one
oh got it nice yeah
damn chin yelled at us
jesus chin there's one more
i told you he was on drugs are you doing
korean barbecue after this
chris nice watch
thanks man i made it i'm gonna watch it
now you've had that i've made it myself
you've had that you collect watches no i
just got this one all right
i made it myself
you made it
took a year now hey the nike sign shoe
yellow huh yeah that's what happens with
these [ __ ] it's the sun i mean are
those the prestos yeah but i never bring
them out in the sun ever
i hunker down in my cave do you have a
window in your closet no
i don't
i don't get it damn peter yan is trying
to oh body shot oh oh
these boys are scrapping scrap yeah
they're really [ __ ] scrappy both of
them i just want my boy corey to get
that bell bring it back to the rules
distance man
i just can't believe the stamina on
[ __ ] that do this dude i don't
do anything for this long 25 minutes of
fighting another grown man i don't think
you get better than these guys it's i
mean how much better can you typically
doug yeah
just unbelievable they do everything
good they do everything now remember the
only reason uh corey's entered because
tj was hurt yeah that's right so the
winner of this is going to fight tj
but tj who does good channel tj versus
corey is a fantastic fight rematch yeah
after corey's made some uh wow
corrections on his technique he's made
some corrections bubba he's made he's
not doing that [ __ ] granby roll
right
that's why he lost the tj grampy roll
what'd you say granby room
what's that it's an old school up in the
kitchen dude i don't know the flavor hmm
well oh boy
oh boy oh boy
all right
just standing just out of reach problem
is you got a reach situation here he's
got to get in there closer and it's hard
he's got to actually let him come in and
then fight him oh god then you get those
shots the problem is for every three of
corey's one of yons does more damage
yeah he's up he's a power
puncher yeah
sits down his punches
small guy though huh yeah he's small
he's small tory's tall man yeah and
corey's not afraid
he's so confident
i was in aurora watching him smart
release right before his camp he was
just getting he's just starting camp yep
he's doing 30 minutes of sparring and he
he was in camp doing 30 minutes
and letting the worst guy in the gym
beat him up because they want to go to
yeah he goes i want to go to the darkest
place
okay you psycho that's a psycho thing
yes like five years ago i was there and
christian just pointed to him said
that's that that's the future
and you laugh like that i went
and then we then we rolled
i actually saw him
sparring a little bit and he threw a
body shot like that and i was like god
damn
dude i said to chris i go how do i do
that he goes it's complicated yeah not
for you though
wow look at this yeah
peter's guess
oh great body shot oh oh [ __ ] oh my god
sorry bubba sorry about that that's what
happens that was a spinning one yeah
that's what happens the spinner one it
was what's hurt him yeah
but now here's the thing corey's no punk
down here he has leg locks for days
now peter controlling that foot
hold on now hold on hold on hold on
daddy oh
oh oh that's tight oh that's in tight
yeah oh no oh weird oh 40 seconds get to
your feet cory
shake him off daddy there you go shake
him off here we are okay at your back
oh he's fine he's gonna turn into him
and you're on bottom
this is how we do it this is how we do
it oh man it's actually the fighting so
much better when you're singing wasn't
that much good i don't know i got more
into it but it has to be the right you
know this is how we do it it's friday
it's gone look at him
he's just both pretty tired now
now i think cory has better endurance
than he does
i don't know bubba we'll see
yeah that was a bad shot that's a tough
one those guys are still still not a 108
right those guys on the top of the post
with the cameras no no that's not
talking why not i don't think so those
guys on the top of the post with the
cameras are they spy
russian spice they're russian spicer wow
that was [ __ ] very funny wow they're
all wearing white dudes 2-1 peter i
think peter peter this is how we do it
for the wedding
when you knock somebody down like that
you got to give it to him
well all the way up and then he knocks
them down so yeah right
i thought it was an automatic 108 round
oh no no no it's rare that you're about
10 eighths these days i mean it's more
prevalent now because they're getting
more educated but
you don't see a ton of ten eights in
there
that was bad the spinning thing really
[ __ ] up right here
oh
that's what knocked out
he rang his back
i don't normally do duets but it's okay
[Music]
it's all good you're welcome but like
when i'm doing it my [ __ ] is so no i'm a
solo performer all right all right
i know it's hard right because when i do
it you feel like
i'm yeah so nervous right now because i
got i got my life savings on this oh
brian why are you betting your whole
life savings on this two thousand
dollars
oh no no oh wow we did a jump [ __ ]
knee that's that's uh that's frankie
edgar out with it who that guy was feels
there [ __ ] corey sanhedrin is very much
in this fight
for about
i will say for about five minutes i was
so tired and i stopped talking for five
minutes
i gotta turn up the [ __ ] heat
[Music]
so now it's on oh oh oh [ __ ] jesus
[ __ ] busted a nut over here you [ __ ]
come on man ah god
keep giannis a nightmare peter yana's a
nightmare dude and every time you say
someone's a nightmare they [ __ ] lose
he's a nightmare speaking of nightmares
i watched [ __ ] uh
when i was a kid i was um
uh
deathly afraid of freddie krueger man oh
dude i had a poster in my room and my
mom i couldn't sleep with it my mom goes
good boys don't have those type posters
and we set it on fire oh wow she was
right
wow but she also bought me the poster so
i was very confused that's uh the most
confusing thing to do to a child but i
will say dude i was terrified of freddy
krueger oh me too well they're like the
poster i don't know oh wow my mom bought
it my friend cliff was really uh
religious and he said that halloween
wasn't if you have decorations you're
inviting the devil into your house your
friend's [ __ ] he's stupid i believe
it i believe you're friends
right he had a haunting in my home and
uh
and uh
i had to perform next i think even with
covert how trigger train's gonna be
popping [ __ ] yeah right now yeah this
time yeah but i was so i was uh
so i i was terrified of freddy krueger
so i was like you know what i never
watched [ __ ] nightmare announcements
i watched nightmare on elm street for
the first time ever see brilliant
recently see brandon what he does it
doesn't really hold up
because when you fall asleep you know
he's curious every time freddy krueger
no i know but it's funny he cuts the
ring because when he falls asleep oh i
know
oh
oh play leg locks with corey
play leglocks with cory santa and see
what happens not a good idea that's all
he does daddy
so um and then i watch part two part two
that's the worst sequel i've ever seen
they don't hold up they don't hold up
now have you seen the freddy krueger
dunk nike dunks now they go for about
six grand yes they're i love them buy
them for me oh well you know it's
they're ex it's a lot of money to buy
for somebody just on a whim like he's
tired bubba peter young's tired right
now both of them are tired yeah i'll
tell you what i'm tired
he's coming forward though you woke up
early huh yeah i woke up way too early 9
15. oh jesus oh [ __ ] oh bam it is dang
it
dang it now that's a spin room move you
you can see though that that that that
guy peter peter yan is just like uh he's
a killer he just goes he doesn't stop he
goes goes goes marilyn brown like that
[ __ ] guy ortega hey remember when
brian said if peter wasn't doing this
he'd be in prison yeah remember that
yeah he also called me a wigger i mean
yeah all right
you've had something weird
cory can take a shot by the way yeah
cory san hagen has got a [ __ ] chin on
him he does now would you give corey the
round with the takedown uh no i don't
know oh take him down they want to do
these spinning kicks
i cannot give him a round he's getting
he's getting cracked and now he's going
for but he doesn't want to he doesn't
want to box with him so i don't like
that and now does this count does it
take that no that no there's no taking
he's taking this back no it's not
takedown
he's defending the takedown but this is
control so it's not good but even
honestly even this much abuse for uh
scent uh sanhegan that that's not good
for him
no do you get mad when michael phelps
gets wet swimming no no no no no no oh
no but i'm saying did you get
do you get mad when tom brady throws a
football and gets tackled i actually do
get angry at that yeah look at this but
i will say um
though
peter you understand later on in life
takes it off his gloves and then he just
answers back
i was in the middle of saying something
i right excited i'm not listening
it's not good for him like by the time
he turns [ __ ] 55 he's going to be
like bar no yeah but it's what you're
saying for chris yeah no i get that i
get that
you can brian said he doesn't like
watching the punishment so he's thinking
about not watching you anymore remember
that be i can't i love this i love the
fight
yeah because i live to fight fight to
live you know what i mean
is that right you're a comedian
yeah but i i i would say corey's down
3-1 yeah
damn yeah i would too and now so he's
got to win now then he needs a knockout
here this is the last round yeah he's
got something in his nose yep yeah take
that out before you fight right oh all
right chris you ever had a bloody nose
yeah yeah
look at how calm he is it's not even
breathing look at how corey san hagan's
not even breathing heavy
well
not really yeah
it's rude what they're doing to his face
they should just let it be
yeah they're trying to fix the cuts and
stop them yeah get this oh look at him
oh wow what's going on here he said look
at me what oh look he's stuck oh [ __ ] oh
really
he's a savage dude yeah he's a savage
he's a young savage
uh now p peter john's the tannest
russian you've ever seen yeah is that
fair to say that's fair to say that's
crazy did he go to like the [ __ ]
salon you'd have to go to the tanning
bed yeah he runs with his shirt off he's
not getting russian son out there no
i've never been there i have no idea
what it's like i think that looks like
you sing a [ __ ] king it's hot in
singapore bob
i think that's what's going on and i
think that you've got his style's not
very singaporish no he's he's obsessed
with muay thai but remember he's a
professional boxer bubba yeah i know
he's very boxy savvy very boxy savvy
i call that boxy god those guys are lit
in the back with those you with the
bubba [ __ ] and the b [ __ ] just just say
brian and
brendan thanks all right man but i'm
just saying yeah i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna go like we've known each other for
a long time when did i meet you
maybe 10 years ago 89 1989
when you were born
wow
trying to get into the club yep it seems
like that
you might be not remembering that right
10 years 10 years oh jesus christ yeah
10 years sounds right 10 years how long
have you guys known each other 14
probably oh okay right better me
i don't but i think that we were both
under the brian's tutelage and we both
kind of
yeah he took my workshop
no where's your workshop i forgot baby
look at this me no oh yeah oh god yeah
they just kind of i'm too into this
fight i can't [ __ ] around right now wow
hey brandon you want to give me the two
grand now or what do you want to do you
want to back out i'll let you back out
if you want really yeah
yeah now you're like oh definitely
he needs a finish yeah
i think so
but we could just roll it into the next
fight companion too yeah
he fought a great fight though you think
colby cummington beats that no i think i
thought i was going to get down there
what about rose and uh zang i go with
roses all day long all day long roads
all day long
all right and everybody
jesus christ i just sits down on those
punches and just throws everything it's
like robert
roberts yeah he does
and he just keeps shutting you down
what's what's the constant pressure
these guys are just going to wake up one
day
they're just going to be like who's
cooking bacon and
nobody's cooking bacon and they just
smell bacon the rest of their [ __ ]
lives that's not bad not a bad thing i
know but it's just it's going to turn
into [ __ ] bleeding brains and cancer
and [ __ ]
that's fair well not cancer but yeah
yeah cory's trying to do whatever he can
doing it's a good fight yeah it's a
great fight good input man
of course trying to do whatever we can i
don't like hey you're being don't be
quietly condescending it makes me mad i
got one for you uh health now think of a
full-blown healthy well-rested tj
dillashaw versus peter young he's gonna
be sick it's gonna be sick tj beats him
yeah um i don't bet against peter yan
bubba i just don't
i can't
i cannot
hey chris stop [ __ ] running
commentary it's a country and i speak my
mind all right
i gotta get a good crypto comment
espn
it's weird advertising does anybody see
that in [ __ ] they do subconsciously
dude and then they [ __ ] get it by
mistake yeah like chris it's what
happens
every one of those apps what's that pink
logo
like you got to make sure it's clear
where oh yeah
oh that's for aliens
yeah it looks very
good visit abu dhabi okay gotta go there
on vacation
it's supposed to be really nice
yeah i heard it it's like vegas on
steroids that's what dude i was just
gonna say that you heard that from hence
like vegas on steroids no i i just i
heard that from hanzo no no tenders
words i do it's like vegas on steroids i
heard that from uh henzel
i don't like vegas though so you put on
steroids that definitely well maybe it's
[ __ ] god damn i just wanna i just
wanna you wanna get in there i just
wanna move out in to montana and just
you wanna go to montana i'll move to
montana with you oh yeah you love
montana i love it
weren't you in arizona for a while with
the fan yeah
i like i like arizona i like there's a
weird uh fight would you move there
right now i mean i don't know man
i don't mind that i don't mind that i
don't mind either of those things but
you like the cactus no now i love just
like hugging cacti i think it's like
piriana's putting pressure so he's and i
don't know yeah
no it's over bro unless he [ __ ] goes
nuts dude you'd have to knock him out
yeah yeah he's got to go crazy because
he's definitely down at least three
rounds you want to pay me in crypto
oh you know what i'll just give you my
uh cryptocurrency oh no you can have my
toads all right
jesus christ is so [ __ ] rough oh god
look at him oh god catching him in the
head like that i mean honestly the peter
young dude he doesn't even look
nope and he looks like he just went to
lunch yep yeah he don't yeah there's not
a mark on his [ __ ] face
and he's so tanned for russian
yeah
that is his hands up like that
oh [ __ ] he's kidding he's [ __ ]
dude
telling you
i'm telling you it's oh
i'm telling you it's bad for you
getting hit in the face it's bad for you
to get hit in the face
i like the way he dances around though
oh jesus christ that's it that was sick
how did he stand
how the [ __ ] did he stand cory lost that
fight yeah he did
now it's abu dhabi so you can get some
shenanigans maybe
with a wheelchair last last move was his
wheelchair that was a great fight
that was a good fight did way better
than alex remains sterling oh yeah [ __ ]
man cory sam then we're married
hold on i love this commercial
remember when i remember when we were at
uh the house with
and it was stallone and schwarzenegger
and all the [ __ ] dudes and uh the
sugar ray leonard and david blaine and
uh guy fieri guy fieri and then we were
watching the boxing and then it went to
commercial and i said oh and al pacino
yeah and i said really i said oh hold on
guys be quiet i'm in this commercial
[Laughter]
yeah dude i mean yeah they're old i
don't even know if they heard but
brendan and frank heard oh that was he
got him with that [ __ ] knee
jesus
that's a good fight
peter's just a [ __ ] tough problem to
solve yes he's a problem he's that
champion just amazing
he just goes forward man yeah god that's
crazy that [ __ ] him
got so many decisions tonight what about
let me ask you a question
what about uh what is it chris so
something that's really been pressing me
yeah no
i actually have wondered this before
like
these guys like
that's got to do besides the fact that
it [ __ ] your brain up and like and like
you get knocked out
that's gotta [ __ ] your jaw up
no sometimes your jaws all off but it
feels goes back right i fight again it
it feels like it's so like
sensitive like you [ __ ] your job
like nobody's the wife is a dime piece i
don't you're not a russian world
champion i'll have it done correct
correct sir you are correct
do you think corey knows he lost this
yes yeah
call him now ask him
quick quicker before they do it
look at the two there's there are
shenanigans hey there's so many bald
guys in the back you got dc you got dana
you have the the [ __ ] commentator
there really are a lot of bald guys what
a baldness you want huh there it is yeah
that has to be a tough pill for courtesy
yes it is but there's no but you're
losing to a phenomenal fighter i mean he
doesn't care i know he's and he's great
look at his little son so cute
yeah
wow
what a stud
what a [ __ ]
stud the girl's distractingly hot am i
right about that
yes she is distractingly beautiful
and he is i heard russians have the most
beautiful well when you when vladimir
putin knows who you are and admires you
sat in russia yeah and he should be like
fedor is his right-hand man
but there you go yeah
how do you not love this guy
he's i don't know man
yeah i mean just a guy i don't know
that's fair he's not just a guy he's a
different guy all right that
commentator's head's weird huh the
commentator looks like the teacher from
south park
okay
you know what i'm talking about this
right there
yeah okay he's a translator bring that
it looks guy up
teacher from south right that goes um
that was an instant classic that was
amazing what
oh
by the way and the push so disrespectful
there he is that's the commentator right
there that's funny oh spot-on
there you go that's the russian that's a
hell of a call that's funny i could have
came up with that if i wanted to i just
did it oh jesus christ
his roundhouse he's just catching yeah
oh god he looks like him that's so
that's so cute dude
look at that this girl is this kid also
doesn't give a [ __ ]
no that's what he knows all he knows is
dad winning he's never seen his dad
loose no he's never saw his dad get
yeah that's it oh for what now alex
remains got a down opponent and that's
how he lost the belt sterling's got the
belt yeah yeah but he but he had to pull
out this fight that's how corey got the
short another shot he is back to being
the champion so the translators
so
translator's
head his shape biggest brain how is that
happening
it's wild yeah well sometimes the way
you're born as you come out can shape
your head just thought i'd share that
with you the way they pull you out right
i know that well he might have a big
brain though mm-hmm because he speaks so
many languages what do you think about
it did you hear did you hear that shawn
your head's perfectly round huh yeah
sean o'malley called peter yana and
peter young just tweeted back smoking
weed again
high high again shawn that's great your
head is perfectly round huh look at
brian's head i don't know it's shaped
like an egg you know what's in there i'm
beautifully symmetrical no you know why
why because he came out of his mom's
[ __ ]
that's so she pooped out juvenile well
speaking of [ __ ] guys you what you
don't want is a hairy [ __ ] and that's
where my friends at manscape come into
play here the global leaders in below
the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 as i like to
call it the perfect package for your
package even your [ __ ] brian if you
have a hairy [ __ ] we can help you out
listen if you get this uh perfect
package inside
you will find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer a weed whacker for your ears and
nose
crop preserver ball deodorant for your
nuts chris
a crop reviver toner a performance boxer
briefs a travel bag to put it all in man
again it comes with a led spotlight so
you can do it in the dark in the water
do it underwater do whatever you want
shave your nuts on your time with
manscape the gift that keeps on giving
and if you go to manscape.com promo code
cfc you get 20 off in free shipping by
going to manscape.com cfc that's 20 off
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com cfc be thankful this
holiday season for the best gift don't
clear your throat in the middle of the
read for the best gift of all from
manscaped your balls will thank you
[Music]
for you
there's three too many you think i don't
know i mean it's kind of cool the way
you're doing it
to be brutally honest with you thanks
dude i want to hate but you're doing a
really good job when you go you you
that's cool
tell me like
you like a lot of stuff like
advertisements you fall for a lot just
fall for it man
my heart
the thick boy heart thickness in the
heart
nah it's just like
you farted man
now
you know earlier you farted oh [ __ ]
that was you no you know that was him
right yes
i find it disrespectful you farted on
the show there was a camera to catch you
winking at me man i swear there's no
back camera is there oh i didn't realize
i don't know
you're the one that farted
it's a slow wing too i'm not winking at
him yeah you are dude who [ __ ] cares
about farts i used to be like yo don't
fart but who [ __ ] cares it's funny
when your kids fart
yeah even my son
he farts he laughs yeah what is that
it's just now he laughs
first time he farted he left and i'll
tell you what and now we taught him to
say excuse me and now every time he
farts he goes he looks at me and goes
instead of excuse me it's so cute
cute to see my son's doing when he he
watches his zombie movie with his
brother he calls him chambees
wow zombies
that's actually a racial slur for
zombies but
uh they don't appreciate it um
but it's cute
be more be more polish looking guys more
tough and and be tougher good work brian
just now how old does glover look he's
41. yeah
looks look how old are you chris he
looks way older than 41. i'm 41.
training dude that's a tough 41 daddy
guys right he's been through the thick
of it but he's but that guy looks he's a
little tougher like buddy no he looks
50. yeah yeah he's just punching the
face for a living yeah and he trains his
ass but he but he looks healthy as [ __ ]
i mean no he's in shape
he's moving like he's 41 though
yeah but don't do this i love this
commercial uh sorry oh [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry i
gotta don't don't buy it i fall for it
man you got it liberty mutual it looks
good it's a bad commercial though look
pretty good how do you expect to sell
stuff like that bro let me tell you
something seriously zero
there are zero good commercials
i haven't seen a good commercial
dude i can make a [ __ ] commercial and
bang it out your sales will go nuts you
know what i would do for real i would
hire comedians and actors to get up and
describe a commercial they would
describe the commercial and that's what
i would do yeah yeah like what samuel
jackson is dumb [ __ ] yeah not this dumb
[ __ ] everyone's scared of [ __ ]
to do some real ad
man
you get me in there i'll sell your pants
they're gone all right sell pants
ah what are you doing what are you doing
listening what are you doing watching
all these commercials this is the one
these are the pants look at look at the
way they look and i don't even have a
shirt on look at the way these pants
look yeah you want these pants okay
that's it that's a commercial i need 30
seconds pants gone so you think i'm
joking
i'm not joking but okay man
oh don't eat don't go double deep in
your mouth sticking your fingers all the
way in your mouth
now what
that's good cheese bro it is nice cheese
boy mike got us that cheese
oh you know what those that those
natural chicken hot sandwiches will be
just in time kyle yeah he said yeah he
said he's about 10 minutes out fantastic
what's the um
what dude i'm gonna i i'm gonna put the
link in my
to this
someone sent it to chris sorry worldwide
bro
but just dude i've called every fight
and we've taken all the favorites i know
it's not all i mean i took all the
daggers i take all the gods the only
underdog you've taken is globally i
don't know
we're both taking globally yeah
but then everyone would have yeah
they'll fight for him tough fight tough
yeah tough fight for him globally can't
count who is this is that glover that's
frank shamrock that's glover oh that is
jeff the [ __ ] out of here
look at him
wasn't he he couldn't get in the country
for a long time you were always talking
about him this guy yeah he couldn't work
here yeah we were like he was like he
was chuckled sparring partner for years
and then if like the hardcores you'd
hear all these rumors about this tough
brazilian you know him and chuck going
at it at the pit training center
world-class jiu jitsu player that's his
background is jujitsu
oh nice
most submissions in light heavyweight
history is that true most finishes too i
think
wait are you sure this is the link it
didn't even pop up as a link
now if you remember john jones
dismantled him pretty easily isn't that
crazy yeah he blew his [ __ ] arm weird
didn't come up to me like that but i'm
sure it works let me try to do it let me
let me hear that how good is it
stupid it's so weird how good he is oh
it worked
he dismantled everybody i mean john yeah
yes monster what is it what is it
like just history i look like a vampire
okay great great i look like a vampire
great
height mentality but it's it's yeah
skill set
i have to believe he works really hard
but people say he doesn't but here we go
he works hard i don't know if he works
as hard like a guy like hey guys fight
plum cam in fight completely
we're doing flight simulator right now
flight center flight flight companion
who's your favorite fighter chris uh uh
still style lender no um
uh john the zendaya guy yeah peter tron
zendaya
[Music]
have you ever seen have you ever seen
our boy um is the dance oh yeah oh my
god he used to be a b-boy oh he was
that's why he did that walkout that was
with his old dancing crew he's such a
great dancer
i was like how the [ __ ] have you seen
that girl he walked out with no oh
really don't even bring her up jen i
don't need that in my life no don't
bring it i got to see it i don't want to
it hurts it's painfully hot now
are you eating a boiled egg yeah
get out
you shouldn't get out leave no come on
dude i don't stand for dudes just eating
boiled eggs okay you can't say it's like
this
look look
you were eating like this dude that's
the [ __ ] no dude that that's the snacks
they gave people on uh uh [ __ ] squid
game chin i know they're good one boiled
egg and remember the gangsters took more
than their share no potato
hey brian
hey brian you know if they remake squid
games you're the old man yeah
hey you little man they better hurry up
they better hurry up and make it though
because soon you're too old to play that
part
it's okay but you pointed at me and you
said you didn't think you wanted me to
join that's why i jumped in too but yeah
so even if i'm like huh oh
there you are where you're the old guy
you pissed his back that's cool dude
you're the old guy who pretended to play
marbles um
[Music]
yep the marvel's one was intense right
the guy played with his wife yes that
made me sad you know if there's a real
games in this room
i win no what
oh yeah you're out of your mind you're
out of your [ __ ] what would you win i
would beat you first of all what would
you win the leaking one hey here's the
thing bro i carefully hey he's got a big
tongue no no you gotta you need a little
thick tie i get a chris christie yeah
that's so great yeah the marbles all
that jumping across the glass
and remember when they played square
game at the end who's going to stop me
there the problem is you're not going to
get there yep you're not going to get no
no no no
no there you go you're picking up
when we sleep at night in the bunk beds
[ __ ] i kill both he kills us
hey with my hands
you first [ __ ] face i can uh figure out
how to how what are you gonna do you
guys gonna team up i know we have to i i
learn how to scale walls
and i and i'm up i'll be impressed
that'd be a problem no dude that's a big
problem
you know the smart guy that just killed
everybody right that's me you would kill
everybody yep we'd have to and then if i
didn't kill you and then we we made it
to the glass part where you jump across
i push you guys off the side
damn it and then we get to that squid
game which is basically touch football
oh yeah who's going to stop me and you
got to which one of you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then we have to fight in the end the
very end you have to fight yeah we have
to fight with that good game thing you
[ __ ] idiot what a fight you're the
knight
you win dude
you could be the rich old gay guy like
the vip guy yeah that'd be cool but i'd
unzip you remember when he was like if
you can get me off in five minutes yeah
i'll let you live but i would i thought
he was going to suck them off we had to
be honest but i would unzip that's the
real thing i don't zip you with a little
knife little couture you're not doing
[ __ ]
no sir just want to make that very clear
if this squid game's not
probably kill chin first damn you would
that would be a problem that'd be brutal
chin would put his name put everybody
against me it would never happen no it's
happened north korea right now yeah
that's real life you think that guy came
up with that idea nah that's it's
actually a documentary yep like you
serious why you sitting like that brian
because my back what's wrong with your
back well these chairs are we need those
rogan chairs maybe
i like these chairs but let's be honest
i think 2000 chairman this is really is
that true yeah what's wrong with it is
it really two thousand it's a very
expensive chair yeah it's not that
expensive probably not yeah see
i know it's a nice chair though i know
but you said two thousand dollars and my
back's fine you want one of those weird
the wheelchairs roasting uses where
there's no back yeah it's better for
your back
i think it does because it keeps
welcome tbn listen
if you want to start your own
no i'm just saying i think we should get
the chairs that rogan has because he
keeps saying wait you keep saying this
is boring
oh sorry blacked out for a second
all right
well oh main events up here we go dude
and then we're getting our chicken
sandwiches yeah dude this is how we do
it this is how chris doesn't
tv show of the year best tv show of the
year the best movie of the year best tv
show your cops
okay
best movie the cops is canceled dude uh
which can watch on fox demand exactly
dude best tv show of the year uh best
movie of the year midnight mass best tv
series of the year dude i want you to
stop talking about midnight mask how's
that dude
how's that
well what's better
oh squid dance no hold on i haven't
i don't know i don't even know if squid
game's better do you watch yellowstone
no but i heard it's great get out it's
good right it's the best really i gotta
watch season sunday two hour special my
bud's in it and they're and they're uh
that's the dutton ranch they're an evil
family i mean they're i play red dead
redemption though huh i play red dead
redemptions i play video games
no i'm not are you new to that or is
that yeah yeah i got back into it i mean
i played when i was a kid but dude i
started playing video games i do twitch
now they're on your twitch flex avenue
follow me you've seen this did you ever
play eric griffin on twitch no but i'm
not really i wanted to yeah did you see
the did you see the mark zuckerberg
presentation beta you've seen that yeah
no what do you mean yes which part get
off his nuts no i'm just he's a villain
i know the matrix he's a bad guy the
matrix is here dude he's a bad guy why
are you saying that though i know i okay
i get it like the property you want
facebook's
crazy yeah all the data that came out of
it yeah how it's addicting and instagram
for kids and they knew it and then
doubled down on it what are we doing
pretty crazy look at it that's what a
bad guy that's he's the new villain
spider-man 4. there you go it is really
weird how much of a
he really does look like a villain yeah
talks on you too
it always like look just this matter
thing is every it's so funny ever since
elon musk came out all the guys want to
be elon musk they're like oh we need
personality it's worth a trillion
dollars
elon yeah but but but but him jeff bezos
like they were no they were not in front
of the camera until they want to be
famous
they want right celebrity now right well
because elon musk is like the bruce
wayne of them and now there's these guys
that and and what's his name mark
zuckerberg is just like i i surf or
whatever the [ __ ] you know and you're
just like okay okay i i surf i serve
that's it good that's good yeah
i eat meat i eat i eat meats and i surf
i have a cooker i have a cooker
i eat meats and i surf hey i like how
you change yeah holograms maybe i like
to change the name to meta yeah because
they're getting all this backlash so
they think by changing the name people
just like okay
well then yeah the new technology they
have is very strange too with vr
instruments but how about the fact that
you can't be a [ __ ]
you can't be a company that's like
taking over the world and it's still
being named facebook that's some
bitch-ass company name
meta is at least a it's a good name
do you know what matters
chris chris
no
i think meta is a good name
chris this is even chris
oh [ __ ] he's got a short
ox
meta
have you seen the
logo
[Music]
it's an infinity sign
meta facebook is
no more
what do you have to say about facebook
being uh bad for young people's mental
health
just makes me laugh
the
data
i know the
data
fake news
fake news
fake news
man he keeps answering yes
[Music]
auto adjust microphone
[Music]
it's getting really great
learning
this is so dangerous
uh
metachris where's chris the real chris
[Music]
in the metaverse well
what did you do to him is he no longer
y'all
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
yeah main event time chris do you know
what meta means
you keep rolling with your shots
do you know what meta means chris yeah
dude anybody 10 points for what meta
means oh 10 points oh [ __ ] wait no i
need the point
it's it's greek for universe no world i
know this hold on it's greek for so
metaphysics
meta metaphysical worldwide it doesn't
mean metal physical like metal metapiece
means i know it for [ __ ] sake meta
metaphysical what would be metaphysical
physical and then what is metaphysical
what all-encompassing no
it's not world all-encompassing beyond
all right beyond yes [ __ ] beyond
physical medicine yeah
i took all my inner christians
education can't be that exhausting too
then when i learn something i get
exhausted
chris you've got to read what what books
have you been reading lately i know you
devour books dune
but you saw the movie i know that's what
i do i watch the movie and then i
secretly i i read the book
i read the chris
kyle crawford bro
no real networks have guys crawling
yeah look at this here we go here we go
low kick from peter yan i mean from my
man look at these guys what's his name
this isn't the set of avatars you guys
walk across
dude these guys literally look like guys
you'd bring your car they are meaty guys
by the way they look like they can get
down there they do look like old ones 42
the other is 39. these guys would fix
your car and over charge you so much
dude you'd be like it's really that much
and he'd be like i know it's everything
is delayed because of kovitz it's just
now one thing you need to know chris uh
glover is a very good wrestler oh great
grandpa very very very really good
grappler he got some oh [ __ ] lover's the
white white guy the white guy
he's brazilian he's a nightmare he's a
nightmare wrestler
don't be surprised if you see a
submission here
although even though he's in the guard
yeah uh no he's not going to submit him
from top guard oh yeah i know my lingo
no bryant said yeah so
did you train with clover yeah you did
yeah black house yeah wrestled with him
did everything spider wrestled nightmare
right wrestling yeah
super stud
now brennan chris what you don't know is
brendan's much bigger than these guys so
what happened to him not really though
no no like he walked around 230 i might
have had eight pounds stronger than he
is
yeah yeah but like he's strong so i was
like maybe 235 238 so you know you
better have eight pounds on them now
you're bigger you bam bam you were 250.
you always saw that back there i've
never seen it drives me crazy i was
never too fast the highest you were when
you was when you did medicinal sir 236
yeah i thought andre alaska at 236
really yeah it's very very true heaviest
i was ever waiting at the ufc was 241
really yeah i was never heavy never 250.
what um
the dude that uh [ __ ] i forget his name
on the bottom no the the guy who
announces all of it the world
championships you know the world champ
no no the dude
sorry
he's black he's got the bald z yes he um
he what does he weigh
right now
yeah well now right yeah yeah okay no i
just want you to heavy weight he's like
240 yeah fought at 205 though for most
of his career fought a heavyweight two
thousand last year heavyweight and
everyone lost never lost to heavyweight
no he did he lost twice dude no i'm
saying when he was before that before he
went to heavyweight like in the
beginning and then he was like
john jones yes okay don't argue about it
but a heavyweight before that's so
nervous guys i don't do well with
confrontation guys i don't do all the
confrontation
well he's saying he never lost don't be
so nuts he
if glover wins this if he wins the title
it'll be such it'll be so [ __ ]
amazing for him great story great story
a great story
ridiculous
now yuri might have something to say now
let me ask you this when you win a
championship in brazil you hail as a
hero the way you are in russia you don't
have the same perks
uh yeah that's i'm in russia or god
brazil though you know
all the people love you why do they
value it so much in russia because
they're that's what they do it's like
they're lebron you know i'm sorry it's
their main sport out there wow
wow in brazil too i mean soccer is
bigger but it's a pretty big deal wow
in america we really don't give a [ __ ]
mm-hmm
yeah yeah you're not lebron yeah yeah
yeah
we got tom brady
okay i'm not arguing i
but although conor mcgregor is [ __ ]
he's huge yeah but he's ireland right
it's it's oh right i got oh i see you're
saying as far as like our i got it i got
it because deontay wilder was
heavyweight champ for a long time no one
really gave a [ __ ] boxing yeah but yeah
really good fun but then tyson fear in
england anthony joshua and england
[ __ ] gotcha yeah that's true but here
we just don't you know we got too many
heroes
that fight was crazy huh the the wilder
fury fight that was curious crazy you
know it's crazy if you knew it yeah yeah
that's how you know it went mainstream
yeah well i watched it oh really yeah
well
paid for it yeah wow
and i but i paid for the ortega one too
the
yeah i i don't know i've been watching
lately i really have yeah well once you
start watching them you get and you've
started the super high level ones yeah
they're great okay like that's just that
fight you saw with peter yan and corey
santana is as good as it gets you don't
get better right now i mean john is
losing every minute of this fight
yeah
yeah he's stealing we'll see if he can
get him down he's cranking his neck
that's called a crazy neck crank because
no one's going to tap no one's going to
tap from that no no a polish guy's not
going to tap from a neck rank although
that's [ __ ] cranking the version that
sucks dude that really
wow there's nothing for me i don't think
i've seen a neck crank in a hot second
yeah i don't think i've ever seen one
look like regular people tap from that
all the time
that's a [ __ ] what do you do when
you're getting neck rank push this way i
[ __ ] all over my opponent
you get so quick okay okay
and you're all covered in poopoo
yeah
i almost want yonder well he doesn't
need a translator i i want that south
park translator jump back in there
yeah but that's polish
yeah bye bye knows polish you're right
daniel cormier cormier cormier ray
cormier
such a badass
he's 42. i mean even the fact that he's
42 is crazy to me crazy i don't know
though like sometimes i think maybe just
because i'm me like i'm like maybe i
look 41. you know you do yeah i guess i
look 41. i guess i do i don't know like
to me you know i don't think of you as
41. yeah because you dress you dress
like you're in your teens right dude
don't you yeah i am dressed like 18 i'm
very
yeah wait how old are you 38
i don't i don't but i feel like it's
different now like 40 is like the new
30. yeah unless you're chris and you
don't do any exercise and you don't take
it i do i don't know you don't get any
you don't get any minerals the only time
i think of ages and i'm not trying to be
shitty is it when with brian yeah i look
older but with like
i can't tell you how theo is no clue
yeah
i know how it is 27 or 52. i don't know
by the way here we go with the strike
steve here we go or bobby lee i have no
[ __ ] clue out there well bobby's 50.
and that that is up wild
that is well yeah now because stevie's
like 48 but he
have no clue they look young as [ __ ]
dude that asian it's just crazy
yeah you don't wanna you don't wanna
yeah
there's no brazilian name yawn well yeah
i don't even know jesus listen man
this is actually exciting
hell yeah brian a couple of meaty guys
too just big meaty guys keep giving it
though yeah meat just a lot of meat keep
going chris yeah a lot of meat they sure
do have meat on them yeah i got a lot of
meat on them yeah dude you guys aren't
playing around
i'll tell you one thing about these guys
they're not playing around
that's a good analysis yep
and watch those knees you know what i
mean
yep that pink logo is so weird yeah it
is i don't understand it's another
language yeah like what's that bottom
it's ch it's chinese yeah it's
narnian it's out of squid games yeah
look at that beautiful [ __ ] he's good
he's that that uppercut that lead
uppercut
yeah oh he's he's like all right you
want the takedowns i can't believe
you've been [ __ ] hit by guys like
this dude
insane i mean do you feel bad for me
no but does it i mean does it
hurt yeah do you feel bad for me no i
know it yeah i do yeah does it i know it
hurts oh
oh my god
yeah oh [ __ ] we can hit now clover gets
power too yeah don't get twisted he
might not hit as hard as young but he
lands that's trouble
back throwing these thangs
jesus oh god
that left hook
that left hook is there for glover i'll
tell you that right now yeah
dude
i'm uh uh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah another
round for glover yeah clover is going to
win this guys it's glover not glover
glover clover huh dude um
danny glover all right here we go
she's related wilbur nice
god man
god it's crazy how much holy mount city
okay i bet john turns to his back he's
gonna choke him out your boy called it
coming up hit me chris i want the
that was [ __ ] incredible phenomenal
dude that's such a journey
it's such a journey for him why why he's
40 he's 40 yeah he's like he's a high
school dude he fought john for the title
and got annihilated and then he like had
a few losses now he's going to choose
knocked out by
he's the world champion anthony he
trains in connecticut you [ __ ] guys
could you bring connecticut jesus
nothing more well deserved than that yes
wow
[ __ ] wow chin's fired up i'm so happy
chin's about to cry why are you laughing
jim's gonna cry because because he came
back from like everything he came back
and then yeah
if rocky was an older brazilian this is
rock wow so brazilian's going nuts right
now of course yeah whatever [ __ ] loss
they'd go more nuts if you lived in
brazil but he's been in america so long
you know dude he's a world champion of
connecticut oh my gosh
oh that's insane
look at that just took that he got his
take when i tell you about him going his
back oh how'd you know though you know
i've been around the game
but like you can't you don't know how
you knew or you do know how you knew and
you just felt it i kind of know dude i i
picked everybody to every winner i'm so
[ __ ] good this is the this is this i
called glover it was in my draft this
show belongs to me guys this show
belongs to me i i kind of won this show
tap quick yeah yeah it's like really
ready to go
that hurts what is the winner of it is
that a chin crank
that was on the neck was it a choker
that was choked
that's crazy he won wow paul felder's
not a word does paul felter not look
like stephen king the paul felder is so
awesome
god damn it that guy looks like he's
stephen king he's a young better looking
son
two bald guys just chatting it up right
now look at that he's just talking about
him amazing he's a champion
that's so cool god he did it now look at
the ref bald what is going on
it must be hymns is all over this promo
code btb all
right bald on bald crimes two rich bald
guys talking about his mother look at
his wife is that his wife or her
girlfriend or whatever it's his wife in
the black
and that might be his daughter with the
blonde dying piece or the uh or or his
mom and his girlfriend no that's his
name that's his wife
again and don't say it's his mom but
that's awesome that's his wife she's
been stuck she's been by him forever yes
you have no idea you have no idea oh my
god that's amazing i'm so happy
look at him how great is that what a
great guy too he's a great [ __ ] guy
wow look at that ref that's made some
poor decisions yeah that's it whoa
that's a lot of tattoos what's going on
he has an ekg on the side of his head
that guy's probably been some dark
artist what does ekg
what do you think he said
you heard a key i don't know i thought i
could
you need to
you need to brush up dude okay man i
will i will i will don't bend
that's the game ah but they could
rematch although yeri is waiting and i
that's a tough matchup for glover
that dime piece yary i would almost
retire now
like he did it no no no but here's where
his crit now is where you get money like
you don't get money here you get money
once you get the bill so now you want to
keep that thing
just two solid guys how about the hair
on the his coach there
where i don't know it's just high
testosterone there's a lot of bad hair
anybody noticing this yeah it's not
really a thing like brian has the best
hair in the octagon did they these guys
fought right didn't they i think no
never no i don't think so
okay there's a translator
but not the one from south park that
guy's been the translator for the
brazilians forever
he's like this yeah
kyle you're into this huh she's falling
in love oh god that was great whoa it's
we've we've been here for a hot second
three hours no this been three hours
three and a half three and a half holy
[ __ ]
it feels like we just got started oh
don't say things that people just say no
no i'm an orange county real estate
agent like you are speaking of orange
county i'll be at the bridge oh god i
remember fourth and fifth any chance you
give them chris november 11th to the
fourth the spot this thursday friday l.a
chris come on guys
i'm only running 30. now he's gonna open
for me you want to open up i'm not doing
it i'm only running 30.
you want to do you want to ten minutes
do you know how close that is for you
bro breath so far
yeah but i'll try it out dude don't
you're not doing me a favor by doing it
i'll throw you up
dude
how long get up there and [ __ ] around
and then i'll come up and i'll
show you how it's done
dude
if i wasn't so hungry i'd laugh at that
we got nashville chicken hot sandwiches
for you dude i'm excited where they're
not here though are they i bet they're
here they're here
they're ready they're hot let's go eat
hey you like hot food right let's go eat
dude you're not selling me on hot food
of course i like [ __ ] hot food hey
it's not your idea hot food hey you've
heard of
cnbc right oh [ __ ] dude this is yes this
is tbn welcome tbn
it's over don't welcome me now
in the thin boy network nope nope
congratulations podcast fans i want to
thank you guys for asking about chris
don't really confine you if they don't
know who the [ __ ] congratulations
podcast on youtube yeah i do it every
week and i [ __ ] you're also on
patreon too yeah yeah patreon
and then dallas that's an improv we're
gonna add shows those [ __ ] almost
sold out get tickets at f a t k z dot
com that is no what are we in [ __ ]
november 11th through the 13th i will
shoot my 30 minute special
dallas
texas addison improv 11th through the
13th and just announced everett
washington one night at a theater in
everett washington i think it's like 30
minutes that guy's your next light
heavyweight champ he's a dime piece way
better look at anybody here either way
everett washington everett theater
whatever the theater it's haunted
whatever november 27th one night only
november 27th everett washington but
dallas you're up november 11th through
the 13th ha this thursday friday guys
love you love you too so glad we did
this this is the fight campaign so the
boys can get back together chris i
[ __ ] love you you're the funniest man
in the world love you guys thank you
thank you for doing this we're out
you